[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right Mike check Mike check with the
realm let us know how to double uses
sounding seeing what's going on in the
room I see some cool names in there
we'll help screen hallo - didn't annoy
young Chris Cali realness what's up baby
Damian Percival was going on I seen
speedy Smith earlier spider that's know
what's up spider is gonna let me know
how my levels decided let me know how
addict levels are sounding come on you
guys yeah we're gonna go at mute because
King has a habit of come here we can
also see a kid come in with a theme song
and copyright striker so we got to be
careful with King pull-up
but yeah I just got to say Kurt
suggested stage what's going on brother
i spaced up thank you brother did y'all
hear addict
yeah I know myself I'm the wolf all
right no doubt Joe Bailey thank you
brother
all right so you shot my beard starting
to look like me a Wolfman hi I'm calling
you - whoa right there you shout out to
the one disliked before we went live
shout out to that do it we like you ban
it salute
yeah you ain't care what we was talking
about is I I'm coming here to diss look
look at that dude that's hot that's how
you know you've grown there's that you
know y'all like them I have about Korea
for dislikes on every single video
before it's even uploaded like it would
be rendering and it's not even a
completely okay what do you got to say
I'm just like yeah we gonna see out a
few busy wait for the king waiver saw we
go chill out good-looking or the love
check
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Souchak number to solve and king or in
the realm make sure you I can hate them
soft cake talk to people when I put up
it's going back and bayonets up get them
payments in the sky the only people I
cared on you are killed on gifts shoot
and then you stab with this thing role
as the enemy
I'll all highs in a building you already
know Maddie going out pilots it's mine
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh right all right and we are live
welcome to the Island Park ass and the
Lords of gaming dotnet episode number
158 what is he's a consistent person
doing that milk run Oh
Sony truck the Lord's Day today we've
got the PlayStation 5 tech demo reveal
impressions Unreal Engine 5 + SSD
scalability ghost of Tsushima
impressions and Paper Mario to discuss
so we go get into it stage let's
introduce the Four Horsemen of gaming
those original Lords in the realm here
at the round table my coals with the
cold most my brother from another mother
the difficult game Kagura Lord of
reviews and the ha of the young wolf my
man Lord addict that we do is they're
doing pretty good man just loading to
the tower there's no one here nobody is
nothing might as well just get that
oh sure we gotta find out the super
careful sweetie Smith mm-hmm
my brother I need the iron Lords intro
for my alarm clock in the morning
straight fire also solutions everyone no
daddy yes we always do appreciate all
the support you guys give us no doubt
yellow to the arm the new Facebook laws
in a chat please say hello see my man
Jason Sanchez first time live on
Facebook that's what's up man we doing
the multi stream thing so he's getting
the Lords in twitch Lords mix of Lord
salute Facebook loss to lose so Lord
what have you been playing sir I've been
playing destiny really unlike you guys I
don't have a level 100 in the season
ranked you okay
and I'm like I'm not gonna have that a
couple seasons from now someone's
sitting there they they show it off
that's lame they CC you I got right the
joint will you put it down like this
that laughs that's fire I go for it I
haven't that man I don't care how wack
it is it might not be whacking six
months no I'm getting it though so
nothing really like there's nothing else
to really play a plane to beat
everything okay you'll get that super
check so we gotta fight all superset
from us so just to save the picture of
kings appetizers last night had me
frying plans quite easy almost 1:00 a.m.
in the morning trying and failing to get
on his level well I'm pretty sure Kings
don't be cooking that we get into that
King's business yeah diem be nice no
doubt and of course our most technical
gaming law the solo game who lives for
the single player selfish experience and
also the sastra Thomas with the flattery
mr. offline profile Illuminati and of
the iron baked mommy
y'all reppin this T spring here baby
Lord sovereign you know a camera right
yes sir the never had this camera over
my is actually dirty never had every
show that he has been on in a hurry I
watched him I'm like god damn how many
shirts to just do absolutely day
I like like 50 over hat boxes of shirts
and yeah well I have boxes of the same
color every color in every style in the
gym with the tank top so I'll make them
know when they open it up to Jim's man
back right we get it
so whatever I've been playing I've been
playing the the ghost of Tsushima
prequels talked about Emily so I'm
playing that um
and now I've been playing I gotta give a
big shout-out true once the
entertainment reading Reynolds void
point games last year's backsies King
and I interviewed so what the iron storm
oh yes yes my god boy so we interviewed
the devs from 3d realms a lot of the
different days whether it's the devs
that it did fell co-op wrath and a fury
which is another first-person shooter
but in particular these deaths from void
point okay a game Aion fury which was
originally called ion maiden but then
the the band Iron Maiden has something
to say about that change the name Oh
so ion fury came out last year on PC and
it's a fantastic beautiful game if you
check out John Lennon's breakdown a bit
last year he broke down actually the
console versions was launched this week
people down yesterday in the video so
check that out from John Lennon on a
digital foundry but the game is out and
I needed to go cop and support cuz a I'm
a bastard and and can't King knows this
too we play these games back of the day
Cod not so much cuz he wasn't that much
of a PC game um a build engine the build
engine is very similar to the quake
engine to the doom engine on the Unreal
Engine those old school 90s engines that
was very important for the time and it
still so this game is built on that
engine and it is the most beautiful flu
then you're gonna see and it and the the
gameplay is very 90's oldschool and when
I say nineties old-school first-person
shooters in the 90 were very exploration
based were huge there was a lot of
Secrets in in in every single stage of
these games plus the shooting felt good
like the shooting especially needs these
build engine games like if you think the
original blood if you think about
redneck rampage ya know redneck rampage
you know what I'm talking about
the original these are all built engine
games and these games anyway this game
is absolutely fantastic
it's out on all platforms now if you
care anything about old school shooters
and honestly how I guess done because a
lot of shooters today don't have the
this type of openness in them this type
of secrecy in them that's why I love
actually Wolfenstein Wolfenstein sticks
to a lot of that in in in in a modern
setting this is not that but yo I gotta
give a big shout out this game is
fantastic King and I fell in love with
it when we first saw it um it's out
there look at the fact that he told us
he said listen um we we have it going at
120 frames per second right now we can
have it go to 240 when he when we sort
of switch when we saw the switch version
away because he it was a debug on his
head it had it going upwards of 100
frames per second I'm sure was hard man
I would hold that no it was running at
120 we saw that what the hell we saw
what I want us and but I guess they ran
it back so they locked it at 30 on
switch
ringback that is a big that is the big
thing is those videos from packs were
the ones that got ruined because the
sound we didn't realize that the way we
never got to post that up but yo that
game looked fantastic on a switch and we
the only ones that had that info at that
moment that same day is the only day
that he had the debug unit out of the
switch and asked a few mind if we
capture off the screen of the switch he
said um okay go ahead because we gave
him so much love on all the other things
they had then it was just like okay yo
you just do this so you know I'm a
little formula works pretty much it
madman a fall in love with that and
playing more AC Odyssey and of course we
have the Incredible Hulk of this aka the
access game ooh the lord of combat
sports king of the statues demands
nothing less than that premium
experience it is the leader of the fraud
alert move it ooh beloved Lord King how
we doing sir
yo did I'm still over in fight last
night yes he did did he was last night
- I'm the oldest ever since they not
doing the whole with the whole situation
it's like I'm out of touch but I heard
he got got got dude out of there
Oh Harris oh he got will Harris out of
it yeah well heard cuz I saw there was a
tweet up say he apologized his fans he
gonna be back stronger I thought it was
sought second round TKO that's what I've
always been about him I liked him more
on steroids than anything are we sure he
wasn't up your look fantastic right now
yo shadow did Jesse listen to this car
chases off work you [ __ ] off my oil pan
yo let's out too just like Weezer the
party chair sees like oh yeah I love
your podcast he's like no doubt you know
no disrespect College we're but King is
my favorite I don't know Paco King so
I think thank you sir all right I wish
see see right now Alice all we could do
all the drugs he want is the only
testing for the Rona Mona Jones you back
on the drugs baby spider super chat from
stitch let's talk about this so-called
tech demo on PS 5 but not know Mario
cardboard not so any PS 5 games that's a
little text in there oh well you know um
this week downloaded a couple of games
for game paths you know I downloaded a
Final Fantasy I've been a parent offline
anyway for a minute yes so um I
downloaded the Final Fantasy okay so the
whole week ever since oh well not the
whole week but ever since um Valhalla
did is dirty I've been going back to
well you know what I got to finish up
this AC Odyssey right so I started off
at level 35 I mean you know like went
back to it at level 35 I'm levels what
is it 60 right now um I'm 75 I was into
the game I've been trying to you know
crush this game there's no question of
this game this game I can have yeah so
um I beat Medusa and I think that was so
epic
yo yeah I'm pretty sure they're gonna
have other stuff in there because
into the old gods guys I like I'm into
that's why I assess increase origins
will always be my top favorite game of
all time when it comes from Ubisoft C
games I didn't care about black 5 I
don't care about little pirates I didn't
care about this was this thing I didn't
care about Italy I don't I don't care
about none of that stuff but this stuff
this stuff that these to crush all those
games to me be honestly the SAS inscri
started with these two those other ones
like you're already on the exact offices
a screen ended with the other ones but I
don't consider them Assassin's Creed
games I consider them like their own
thing I mean they deviated a lot like
but I yeah what I heard about how I was
doing is bringing back some of the stuff
from the old games that they cut out
like like a one-hit assassinations like
in AC one and two like when it came to
assassinating like the big hits yeah I
would leave I would sneak into their
compound mm-hmm jig doing with it with
the hidden blade and maps that was the
assassination now I hated I played it
like a splinter cell game right you
can't you could do that in the new games
but the thing is especially with AC
Odyssey since everybody has a health bar
that's you're a couple of levels above
them it's not gonna kill anyone it you
don't taste the enemy scale you can you
can change it right if you have if you
plan on normal and normal scaling you'll
always probably be on the same exact
level as hardwood with like a certain
type of level scaling it'll always be at
your level so you always have challenge
but then when it comes to Merkin people
and silent assassin ation you're not
gonna see a lot of it and I'm glad they
do change the crap I just didn't like
the legit tanks you know what I like
about this the jumping mode the jump
mode you could be in a serious boss
battle fight and then two more red bar
dude will show up like yeah remember
that joint you said change you know this
past week I had I had the
the bar fall I literally had six
mercenaries on me at once I mean the
thing is some of them were like level 70
yes like you all fighting that game I
ran away there's no point of running man
we're all mountain and drop them notice
if you have the arm of Achilles deadly
if you have the immortal armor you're
basically on impotent but right now I'm
wearing the Greek heroes armor right oh
and I have the bowl of Achilles so all
the stuff like I'm wearing um Jason's
Golden Fleece oh that's because I'm into
all that mythology stuff but um I only
said this because remember this started
off with me down a little final fantasy
right don't go from this graphical bliss
and all this other stuff throw on Final
Fantasy is to gray bars no oh it's not
fair to uh to judge a game ps1 over a
game that came out last year - mr. Aries
or twitch me that's what I do please get
me to the lighthouse sir good to see you
on Twitch but the Lord continued King
right so I tried to press the button and
see and um I'm so far away from the TV I
didn't have my glasses on or whatever
and I'm pressing some button and the
speed and the framerate light I'm like
moving around really fast no I'm not
gonna front the polygons look great they
look great like they they put them up
probably to 720 or something like 1080p
but the background is still 44 40 P it's
like you took a a dream as game and put
it on top of a switch background
I don't know what was going on oh no oh
no doubt no doubt
do me a favor um kill somebody get on
twitch on Attock if you can we got to
make somebody mod over there something
get little rambunctious over there I got
you des what was said I'm not fast set
it up in a minute okay
all right so okay so I did that Oh turn
I took the dust off my place at the
exact motion you made oh yes I did
literally our minds on it right did you
know when you turn on the jet engine
starts to itch so I had to do that did
the updates and they had to charge up
the wack controller because you can't
you don't have the option you know you
must charge this controller so charge
the controller up and then I started
playing for sine of five um but I
quickly jumped off for that and I went
right back to Daisy Odyssey because it
has my addiction right there he said I
get Iceland the Final Fantasy 9 David
knees are full okay listen listen yeah
listen I'm sorry bro I am if it was it
was great back then when I purchased it
originally
right and this is why you do not release
a game the same exact way you did 20
years ago I said you said oh yeah it is
the goal but you need to watch the goat
up aging well sir I guess they got a
final fantasy seven ago they got a
higher better Unreal Engine five that
goat is just go have a chain on he got a
Rockefeller chain but that's all I've
been playing and I'm gonna finish with
some AC Odyssey as soon as I finish this
today no of course we have the game
himself the shinobi nor Cognito sprite
never owned us in a row man I obey hey
watch it
they'll tell you what you would hear but
you need to hear but yeah yo shout-out
to Sarah is Stephen to tonnes studios
they got their demo out of unto the end
it's on Steam right now for the weekend
so yo check it out man shot the cat
daddy was getting it in son
they they go okay on myself man I don't
want to spoil it for myself I was
tempted bro it's obvious he's got it
yeah you know it's down when you get to
the title screen and you just sit there
and whoever's what his sound team they
crackling of the fire and then you know
saying why he has got he's got the
torment guy his son and wife he bought a
campfire and then home she's humming
like this tool so I had the head of I
was like family I was like you what I
told Eggman
so yes salute to him he's deaf like I
said I got a bit let you play for about
30 minutes the gameplay not too much not
too much just to get your little feel
what's going on atmosphere is a may it's
literally like you you have a lot like
alone in the door I mean I out of this
world I'm saying with the ambience where
it's like yo what's the distance what's
going on you know they like it's one of
them games
and then you got the combat the combat
yeah cat daddy says about fifteen to
thirty minutes so to combat it takes a
little while to get used to they got
some training and joined you I'm saying
but everything right now is in you know
it's in the beta as far as a demo they
still working out King see they still
doing stuff but they take your feedback
so if you have feedback please you know
send it over to them so salute to them
you know saying they getting close you
don't say anything this year I guess it
comes yet it says would I be they said
um 2020 join its detractors and they
commemorate day out in a gotta solutely
out gamepad coming again pass so if you
ain't all PC it's coming all platform my
playstation nation is coming to y'all to
switch game coming in hot all that unto
the end
look it's looking good so far so I've
been doing that shot the attic put me on
today guess tactics I downloaded it on
my PC so yeah I'm gonna flip flop I am
here pull it up it was it was only
chance so what we calling out these
frauds acted we will get to a lot hold
you I know you're too new for the the
200
go let's get those likes cuz it helps
that Al Gore listen ah [ __ ] I heard this
from booms algorithm when you hit the
likes and it also allows us to get more
so once we get over a hundred fish we'll
go to our audition
turn the beat around
okay so and in this is uh sorry this is
cod joint being a wheeze doing so many
reveals and stuff like that um that box
is still been sitting there ready to get
done okay and I got another statue this
week that I'm super excited about that
it's like a little bit more like what's
in the best copy yeah but usually I do
the show and then they already seen it
and then shot that gave the s shot the
Sinister yeah I'm feeling Gabe Diaz as a
protagonist I don't know what's gonna
happen we notices the pass right but so
good easy easy I don't know that you
know I understand I'm just saying gaming
make it we all never see like Gabe could
be alive in the current thing the
production values are insane though I
did about the brew Mac fight oh man it
took a little bit of my soul but people
are saying that ain't nothing compared
to the fight you with the bosses you'll
have to fight later but your salute the
gears tactics can't outwit console guys
get Xbox guys get it they're really
gonna enjoy can I say something because
I seen bone slave inside the chat
shout-out to my brother you know I
really starting to feel it now like a
journalist quarantine joint I'm really
starting to feel I'm not gonna see y'all
this year really quaint yo to crash out
the sentence they say yeah the bosses
got better yeah man I don't really know
you blaze I know how you get with them
type games I've been doing that
like I said on today and shout the
streets are raised for I'm gonna
continue to shame you on ILP every time
we go live the game pass version on PC
I'm gonna continue to shame you
we now have got it to launch so remember
it was two three weeks we couldn't
launch it without doing tricks and all
type of stuff yeah on PC now we get it
to Lord shout the carboxyl for the rest
the race for not allowing me to do co-op
shout out to troubleshoot game child
troubleshoot is it is still a hot mess
not again no disrespect steam version
you guys will steam you guys are fine
I'm talking about the free iced tea
might be fine with this game we get a
little feel shout out you don't find out
so much at how many first party devs
using modified under Unreal Engine tech
already and ready for launch for Xbox
next gen who did that for yeah I got a
shame that because this is unacceptable
with the issues now again I'm not gonna
throw the Xbox under the bus all the way
cuz I still don't tell me to get this
patch going and the certifications go
but it's too slow like if they want to
make that cry for I'm serious cuz I want
to make a serious soft like I want to be
over there go back and forth and you had
these little issue this word attorney
about now in their defense guess tactics
has no issues been rockin no problem but
that particular game streets rate for
the game past version on PC game packs
what Xbox is live nothing going on with
that they do that update I was talking
about with this with the missing stuff
I'm not sure that's the whole bunch of
stuff happening on the all these game
past commercials I'm seeing popping out
all over the place every time you on
YouTube and like a like you let's say
you click on a digital foundry video and
I notice it it's specially key if it's
on a Playstation anything that's a
PlayStation for anybody that got a
PlayStation platform when you go to
click on that video game pass pops up
and it says find your new best game
something like that your new favorite
game on game paths so it's kind of crazy
they got a bunch of them so that's fully
with the fire dollar super jet set up to
the iron Lord shout out to the family
and
chat everyone that's that like button is
so gonna be fire oh the crust up hip-hop
is in there for my mind ha brothers I
laws all the JRE help out I need you
back cuz you gotta bring your knees to
me I saw a ghost Ashima a straight set
in ether dis track to Lyle aesthetics
where is Roux at win Willie Andrew and
shoot straight for ya here in the game
but he just had the ball you don't
saying I don't know it's normal shout
out to the four city on Twitch
you know I say I see that I see that but
yeah that that's been that for me the
like I said the Streets of Rage I gotta
get that going and then I am on
Destiny's hiatus because I am not
feeling what they're doing right now I
saw the last word and I saw your ranting
in your okay you know what listen listen
being that I'm the only one that's gonna
keep being vocal about this last word
because I watch religiously it's like
you're just like a telenovela for me um
I'm at the point right now I have a
screen shot him tell him you're watching
you he did some stuff for you like
closing your windows and stuff i'ma tell
you I'm feeling you dude this is God far
the worst ever they have definitely and
I see what they purposely doing they're
holding us back thank you I'm actually
having fun
would you salute salute the aid that go
forth they that go what is it a not
gonna put the banana in the tailpipe
King they just gave us the desire of
towers gonna get into the season and now
they want to do the joint again it's
like your community come together work
as the same person that wasn't filling
us going the moon again
we just did it was different it's like
you know what we done we had the last
word please watch that last show so you
can know how hard this dude is fraud is
right now he's absolutely you know I
swear to God I would have never gave him
this fraud alert but I'm sitting there
with my mouth open like I can't believe
this guy we got a boy cat we got a
boycott man we go I gotta watch you live
so I got to start jumping in your chat
slab and same with your frauding anyway
low revolt going on right now until we
get some actual proper cuts a hole or a
whole roll one away draggy already know
Brooklyn stand up out of some chat call
my doctor van come from Ghostbusters
Ghost addiction has to be put in the
containment unit
whoa oh not like this one away we can't
be doing that like that Brooklyn come on
Brooklyn let it get $2 super charm
stitch King they even added a mission
called the lie no it's true that is true
that is good
of you if you watch them they put they
go in on that story but um yeah man we
got to get this pull out the way last
week's poll results are in and the
people have spoken to the question with
the latest series X gameplay reveal
event
whom do you deserve most blame for it's
mostly negative reception from critics
the winner of a fairly competitive
four-way ILP poll at 41% was yes Xbox
deserves the most blame for over IP gave
Lane come in that second place at 26%
was gamers yeah built up expectations
too damn high coming in at dark plays
very close at 24% was third party grabs
Microsoft can't force developers on what
specifically to show and last place at
only 7% was I don't care I still got my
playstation 5 logo and controller reveal
room so shout all the Lord through
winning in this song you are the victim
so you feel that smoke that's why it was
literally one word that derailed their
whole did listen to this it was one word
that derail the whole thing and I've
never wanted to defend the internet but
the whole internet can't be wrong you
can so be wrong the only vocal majority
that you're listening to is the Sony
dudes I mean I'm honestly I'm sorry I'm
just like I'm absolutely fed up with the
hypocrisy that I see in level girl I'm
funky right now you know I know
Apocrypha is this sickening it's
sickening
you know am i man for this know the
words and ask me yeah that's the only
time the Sony dudes ran out and hit that
pole up because I will tell you right
now listen why don't you talk about the
chugger man that framerate on a dag on
demo we don't get in today be with the
PO like I said we would have to do would
going up and all that good stuff but we
got to get it to these topics man a lot
of
going on right now obviously we you were
talking about said demo so while Ken you
want to bring it to the round when we go
set this thing up sit that up please
because I'm gonna get into these do so
looks like yeah there was a reveal this
week right there on Unreal Engine it was
actual gameplay of the forest did it
actually with the Lord's entertaining me
while I wash dishes on my wife let's be
plays planet a game past fire sort and
visa so fantastic game um you'll see hip
hop that's how it's done anyway there's
actually some YouTube videos out there
somewhere hip hop that shows how you do
a super chat
don't try to get my man's up in any way
so look we got to try to reveal
first-time PlayStation 5 heart we're
showing the tech show what could be done
so I want to bring it to the world
probably to you know say first just the
impressions of the devil go do the tech
part and what I'm doing and all that but
just the impressions of the demo so
first first is a little misleading yeah
first let's let's mention let's be very
clear
mm-hmm this is this is demo from an
engine that's on all platforms continues
a little misleading because they wanted
to act like they were doing it on final
PlayStation kits and I mean well final
PlayStation hardware they keep saying
PlayStation hardware and it's kits and
in the background I'm privy to a couple
of bm's and now I'm going to explain the
hardware is not finalized fellas now
even at this late stage in the game it's
not finalized but going into the infra
and I'm going to get into that later but
going into the impressions of what I saw
right it is a technological masterpiece
yes it is we can stop acting like we
don't know how unreal and epic does yeah
thanks unreal and epic has powered a
generation basically this generation
because a lot of our greatest games is
using the Unreal Engine a lot of game
developers that were in trouble
switch to the Unreal Engine and got the
game up and running with great assets
and actually been coming and as some of
those games of the generation of games
of the Year candidates isn't our final
fantasy I mean through Mortal Kombat 11
or last I forgot how glorious that look
he's like man oh you were good playing
that on that switch could I I was I was
so happy so that it came out a switch to
like a ball again and I played
exclusively the story go switch so then
if the aftermath is about to come out
and I'm getting ready I said let me play
or
what you call our necks do you see the
scalability of their engines so when
they say stuff like this is scalable on
from a mobile tow to the highest end PC
you know and consoles is in between
consoles always be in between there you
know the ice and ice and and PC will
always destroy a console so like just
will win
you know attic said would my PC be more
powerful than my access what um all I
just need to do is add an SSD to it just
smash this right into the face and Milan
king we gotta do super check them all
know how to go shout out to 108 dragons
TV with the fight out of super chat
shout out to Safa being on camera
history was turning into the Captain
America ponies on that Sony
if I wanted to just play with one gun I
would have played destiny to begin to
the season it just plays hard light all
season yeah but I just felt that the the
level of detail the what the geometric
engine is doing with the damn near
billions of polygons triangles yes
on screen it's giving you a level of
fidelity that is unmatched right now by
any engines that we've seen so far but
being that this is the only and I and I
have to stress this to you guys again
this is the only engine that has
presented itself in the next-generation
format now alright so don't don't go
jumping out the window yet until you see
CryEngine
then how the decimal engine goes up how
other engines there because there's not
just one company that does engines
there's other engine couples we gotta be
real here though what the Unreal Engine
is used on the majority of the games
that we do play because Tim Sweeney
definitely is a billionaire he can tell
you he could tell you the silliest thing
that I've ever heard but it is the most
but are we gonna talk are we gonna act
like the majority of xbox trees aren't
using the MRO yeah especially if you
give a caveat as you look at themselves
a million then you can start don't you
every time there's an owl he literally
says and this is for the little devs
this is you shore up your base and makes
all the indie games look great you tell
them well until your game makes a
million dollars it's free rah I might
make a game right now
lots of chat well place changing games
go to PC that that there's to be only on
the epic game store epic shows new
engine on PS 5 and Sony didn't even give
a tweet he might say I've been saying
this for the longest time
no I didn't even think about that angle
but overall your impressions were strong
oh it was it was magnificent it was it
was how well see they do it every
generation with the new iteration of the
engine right but it was it showed me not
this speed when she is flying through
the air right to hell with that when she
was walking through the the statues and
you saw the light off of the light in
her hand the blue light and you know you
pass all a little chugging here in there
but because they didn't show it on a
powerful PC they showed all the lowest
em on a pond on the next generation
what you're saying is easy saying you
know that they popped a they stuff off
on the wrong console and a little bit on
the this is what you do you get the
least common denominator man you say
c-come on this what the X will do is
crazy
[Music]
is he wrong week we know is the weakest
console bus even act like is not it was
supposedly engineered but I do not like
I do not like people yelling out but
that SSD made it super fast it was
flying through the air super fast its
confirmation it was not using it was not
using a full power of finish I'm
surprised what if it comes out there
wasn't even had an SSD hooked up to it
at all I'm just saying this right you
know what I think you're onto something
don't know what a SSD is because they're
coming from a console right you talk to
PC shout out to Mom's for being here
because so mods can explain to these
people that don't understand an SSD does
not run it is literally just a white
more advanced storage just literally all
- we will talk about it but overall you
were impressed we got we got listen I
say oh my god it made me think of what a
Jedi fallen order to will look like what
next Tomb Raider will look like it I
thought it was a game I was just hunting
but I was happy at the same time that
okay it's not a game but these assets
will be used because their last demo of
the Unreal Engine 4 those dream assets
were used in other games later on that
you saw not the assets itself but
polygons the power that use in it I
think they realized that at end of this
generation with the Unruh
for I think it reached his potential so
if this Unreal Engine 5 can reach its
potential its potential is what we saw
on screen right no doubt that Janssen
with the file on a simple check how much
money for me to come in and roast brats
hypocritical but claiming PlayStation
Bob like it is big he was in my talent
he was on my tweet so Oh that'll be take
a John what's going on to build it all
right so we got before we get my dough
boxes in the building go talk tech I
gotta get up and we get the rest of Lord
first addict you you you were I got to
say sends it to say to the father also
be chat in videos measures demo had more
than double the number of polygons on
screen at 50 million drawn three point
five trillion triangles total more than
the demo yeah I mean you think about
Nvidia you know the funny thing is
they're pretty soon in videos they
talked about ampere but ampere right now
is not they haven't talked about the
gaming applications necessarily for
ampere just yet um but once the you know
the 38 EES and the 38 ETA I start
getting talked about it's gonna it's
funny cuz everything we're talking about
now is gonna be sort of sort of null and
void like a the PC is gonna step it up
yet again which is always what happened
always but but not to say anything what
we're getting is impressive for what
we'll get so he saw was impressed right
into you soft okay one more one for 108
dragons to the Father
yeah let's not forget that EA Ubisoft do
not license their engines out epic
Unreal Engine is made for devs on all
platform as well as unity that's right
we haven't even seen what unity is
different let's give a shout out to own
one or a dragon um my man is definitely
back and full effects and hold off
Christopher Hart is in here okay
Christopher hard for the a $1.99 super
jet this is how it's done my man
Christopher I respect that
PlayStation 5 SSD superior series as
is the you know what you're right you
are absolutely right yaaaaah no he's
right
the funny would say Zod something she's
on or something because um the the SSD
drive is definitely a way more capable
of a SSD than X but at the same time you
don't have a terabit of it um I don't
know how it's gonna fill up and we don't
know how is going to work theoretically
we how it works being that I think this
is your first console generation no no I
really honestly think this will make
this but my age this is baby's first
console kognito and sovereign about this
because I give no compliment and then
knock him dead we thought the Saturn
that on paper the Saturn was superior to
the PlayStation in execution see what
happens with that but you're right that
that is true I'm not gonna shame that
that's the truth no doubt no doubt let's
get LMNOP or file a super chat so when
will we see the character we control
having those crazy [ __ ] 9 teraflops
is less intuitive why we go here we go
with the Flex yes transition right in
just your impressions of the demo and
we'll get mods in a building okay so let
me talk about my impressions of the
presentation first correct I wanted to
compare like the actually the way they
did it right I thought they got into the
presentation quickly which I loved and
folded it with all the talking
afterwards okay I'll just like just like
the game awards like the game awards is
going through a lot of changes and
growing pains to the point now what
Keeley understand
in order for it to be successful you
have to okay you actually you have to
you have to big up the devs right that's
what the awards are for right but you
have to focus on the main ones that
everybody knows about alright the game
director game of the year stuff like
that's what people want to watch in
addition to the reveals the reveals is
the biggest thing that brings people to
the show with this because this is this
is what Keeley wants moving forward
right we're gonna have some some some
form of in-person type of event but this
is what Keeley wants so this has to
improve so did that whole half-hour
conversation afterwards I'm not about
that I'm not about it just look I
understand it oh we did but yeah you
know record that put it off to the side
you don't want that as part of the live
show which slows everything down um so
that said I have been its own YouTube
video exactly something apart um that
said I agree with King when I when we
talked about the Xbox presentation this
is kind of what I wanted to see right
show us what the machine's gonna do
and again that's expectation on our part
but this is this is what I want to see
now that's exactly what which mean can
do exactly that said right we have to
take a lot of this what a grain of salt
if you look at but you go back to when
they first of real unfair and in for
three same thing it took quite some time
for the games to get to the point where
they even comparable to what the engine
was showing off right how many years
yeah exactly
exactly so I mean so to expect that from
out of the gate I think is is is is
overreaching a little bit if we do get
it I will eat crow if we do I will eat
crow completely if it does first stuff
out of the generation kind of looks that
way um so I thought the demo was great
what I didn't like is this sort of cap
and like 1/8 when they said this is that
you could plug into control and play
this cool you're not gonna control and
play this not what does that mean to you
does it mean that I can plug in the
controller and walk the exact same path
does she walking in the
or can I stray off to the side and and
check out what's over on the left or
check out or is that even ready what
does this mean we both know what that
means you know forget about you know the
you are asking a rhetorical question
yeah forget about ponies vs. BOTS and
stuff like that just in general like we
need to be gamers need to be smarter and
better about the information they take
in and disseminating that information
and understanding it because come on man
like really if you tell me you can plug
in the controller and you can walk over
here and climb here and you can walk
over here and climb here that's
different
no you're telling me the same path that
she walked in the demo I could do that
and okay so what about NPCs when you
account for NPCs when you like it's it's
not quite that so it's a little
disingenuous to be like you can plug it
in this is what it is
on the PlayStation 5 that's not fair
it's not fair to do that and it's like
oh and I noticed this often times you
know we get treated like we're idiots
like they try to get pull fast ones on
us on both sides of the argument
it was guys so are we saying that this
demo with hardware is not frauding
language again has to be questioned the
same way
what he's saying is what they're saying
what they're doing is two different
languages and they don't meet up with
co-op is questioning that like as if
it's a predetermined path on Rails and
it
you can't venture off Jonathan we solve
as questions as it is problem that is
probably the case that is probably
absolutely wanted to present the case
and so we need to be cognizant of that
when we talk about because and the thing
is there are people out there people out
there talking numberings don't know what
they're talking about like listen I love
this stuff I love the numbers I don't
know what the hell I'm talking about
like I'm going about what I hear and
what I
and I read in-depth into his playing in
which he said it was a controlled mo for
I be dealing with I was a very
controlled mo so again let's keep
because the same way that he gave
Microsoft to join that's been this
lashing out just because Microsoft got
bad PR with their game this is what
happens when you don't keep the energy
in the same way to you something that we
gotta get this image out to me but
beyond that it's impressive and if we
see that level of fidelity it's Jen I'm
gonna be very impressively very happy
right on what we'll talk about later
when we talk about um go sakushima we'll
talk about what I feel like is not
happening in the guts in the guts of
games like premier you again
gamers gotta be better man like we we
get all blustery and happy when we see
high graphics in the guts of things you
know we always vertical slice the Fidesz
we just like we get weak we fall in love
with fidelity we fall in love with
framerate and at the end of the day
we're we're getting a lot of the same
type of games just in different clothing
and we're not we're not necessarily
addressing that when we speak to these
things you know I mean let me let me say
something across for Chris it wasn't a
Sony event Oh like I'm I'm sorry I gotta
break it to you sir um I know you're
starved and I told you on on Twitter I
feel you I feel you I'm me - I'm
starving - I like my plate of Sony alone
there's no plate I can't take pictures
of that plate so there's no you know is
one p one juice and in one nugget now
but in case you ain't noticed key needs
a full play when when you actually get a
PlayStation 5 game because what
Microsoft was showing you games that
you're going to play this year and neck
who actually get a game and not a tech
demo paid for and financed by Sony with
another billionaire trying to prop up an
engine that's going to be it's like
repet it's like wrapping a used car
renting a used car talking about it's
yours no it's for every don't pom-poms
for that wait for PlayStation game to be
announced that you could be like yes you
could wrap that because you reppin an
engine that everybody gonna get a turn
on like something hmm
you saw a Gears 5 lady hmm so I would
like hold back on the enthusiasm sir I
just look we gotta get these super
chests attic solve I need you I hope
because we be missing I don't even know
where we're at all the C Dave
okay I think I think we're on stage
peace Lords hit the psy the next model
is pure trash I don't think I think
that's where we left off so what said
nine teraflops is less than twelve we've
got a two dollar super chat for memory
definitely what's your name my apologies
peace Lords the PS 5 Unreal Engine face
bottle was pure trash I've got a
children's super traveling cat daddy
fast at 33 teraflops is more than 12 30
atti mastery that 38 et is gonna be
graded get safe okay hold on we got sage
so Jitsu sage with a $10 super check
series X SSD before compression can load
eight gigabytes into RAM in two point
two seconds add s FS right yeah only one
third of half of that may be needed for
same visual result how fast point seven
four seconds and 1.1 seconds
respectively
no both my head the bar hello better
peel - awesome chant that tech demo was
an interactive cutscene I think we got
that and then somebody gets stitch we
got to find out super chair from stitch
pcmasterrace is the goal but what are
you going to do with all that power when
you can't play any games because all
lobbies are filled with cheaters
you got to put these onto something yeah
you get in or something for that way
they're gonna be a little spooky with
the bowtie playing competition
yo shine we got a $2.00 stripper chair
from Smitty strip down or injured
belongs to the street let you say salvia
finished up right yeah I finished up man
I again I'm excited if this comes to
fruition but we just got a temper are
our expectations a little bit out of the
gate yeah listen Mike Chris yes good new
Mike so yeah actually that's like this
show with the Mike so it's good I'm kind
of testing it right now
my South Fair is incognito you want to I
gotta make it for lost time to say I
have watched your video and when you
broke it down I said he broke a lot of
dudes hearts we just I want to get you
to real quick
obviously we just talked with a query on
the Unreal Engine tech demo place it's a
five hardware just the impressions first
no technical stuff yet just your
impressions of the demo so mods you're
up first and then let's get dealing yeah
thanks um Heidi like yeah I mean I was
super impressed I mean like listen I
would have to be blind not to see the
graphical fidelity and up and stuff
right I mean I was impressed with global
illumination I know it's not ray tracing
and ray tracing would probably be better
but like you know seeing what we've seen
anyway it's like very impressive anyway
right like all those reflections yes
all I know is none of this happened on
the switch even a shout-out to gone to
see mobile devices he said mobile device
let's go yeah so lighting was great and
obviously lino lighting is very
important for the whole kind of like
realistic feel and look to be honest
with you right but like what I was
really impressed with was obviously the
amount of geometry they were able to put
on the screen right so I'm not regoing
to like into like no too many too many
too much detail about it
like you know you can actually like see
everything because like usually you've
got like you know up a rock right and
you've got like some slab of texture
base you put on that and some desolation
whatever right but know it this time
around you've got like an eye nice
rounded Rock right this and it's an
object not like a flat texture so that's
that's totally different but obviously
the amount of geometry that put that dad
that was very impressive and like
generally speaking like I was I was
really impressed so the and and they
were really hyping up those two those
two techniques this I forgot the name
yeah me new a newness minute on the
night yes so that's the that's the the
whole geometry thing right where you can
actually stream that from very fast from
SSD whatever right and obviously the
aluminum so the lighting that was very
impressive and you know and I get that
it's just a demo and you know we we
that's not right like a proper game
we're not going to play it right
although from what I'm hearing actually
we will be able to test it out all you
have to do is just download Unreal
Engine 5 once it's out and apparently
Tim Sweeney actually said that everyone
will be able to test it out on PC right
so obviously it's not as easy as
downloading the game but I'm sure that
some PC guys will actually test it out
on their on their you know PC rigs for
sure so I was very impressed with that
demo I'm sure that some games will come
close to what we've seen right however
last comment on that is that I found a
very interesting comment about whether
it will be really possible to make games
like that right and I do believe that it
is possible because a it was running
life like real like real time on
PlayStation 5 but I'm not sure if it's
near this comment from Roth grazetti and
his arm I think he's a designer at Santa
Monica Studios right so the guys that
created a go to work and he was and this
is what he actually said quote CUDA
kudos to the art
that can create with this fidelity for
30 plus hours of gameplay
then somebody chimed in I won't truly
name this person because it doesn't
matter he basically said well actually
you can make that scenes with mega scans
alone right so he was actually referring
to those film like kind of assets that
you can actually upload from you know
some website whatever right and he
replied yeah try to make a 30 hours game
with mega scans let me know how that
goes
fantastic so reality of it is that it
all depends on the size of the team
budget how long how much time you've got
so can you make games looking like that
yes you can but how many developers will
really have budget to do that and time
to do that well I guess we will have to
wait and see no - at this stage with the
Slayer - lots of Jeff Falls today are
stronger than a switch cog continue all
right so we're gonna get to talk too
much so Lord dealer man I mean obviously
we've got that revealed we got to get
into the deep aspects that Isis the
other tech stuff next but I wanted to
get your overall and feeling impressions
of this devil was it that good is that
bad no I mean it's good I just
remembered
trolling attic he texted me he said what
do you think about that demo I said this
should tell back because on PC now right
I'm trying to use the logically gives
these people but uh again see that I
know you didn't I gotta comb it down
no Alex amazing he's a good friend but
are you gonna say good cuz my video
exploded I have no why you know YouTube
guys whatever 350,000 views and I don't
know flex I know
I don't know but when it comes down to
it as I said in the video I'm very
impressed by the the Tecna MOU I feel
like if Xbox guy I saw this on an Xbox
showcase they wouldn't say a thing about
it and I feel like that is probably one
of the best-looking things we have seen
coming out of the next-generation talk
yes and it's demonstrating new
technologies you don't really seem to
own Xbox or Playstation today so I liked
it and it wasn't really even a first
party thing it was more of a third party
kind of deal with epic and when Sony are
gonna show a bunch of amazing software
on top of this that's what people can
understand so the whole 1440p 30 talk as
I said in the video this is not
optimized they are showing off at this
point look we got a million triangles
from 7 to 17 billion polygons per nipple
on these statues there's a billion
statues in this room and you can't even
see 14 of them you know like they're not
optimizing in any way whatsoever on the
stamina demo hmm and I feel like if you
wanted to double framerate you could
easily checkerboard this you could
easily do a lot of things that
optimization to get this up to 60fps and
on series X they're gonna look even
better
okay says you know retrace new hardware
was not even in use there right series X
has all that compute on top of the
additional ray tracing Hardware they can
handle up to 13 TF of traditional
software ray tracing I you know again
I'm very excited for the future I like
the way this demo look I had set it in a
damn video this flight powered part of
the of the demo was possible on series
ax and I we know that I mean look at the
spider-man SSD movement test they did
that cameras flying so fast the screen
ripped off of itself this looks an even
close and you know they already
confirmed this will run on PC they ran
out of 20 80 max Q and a laptop and it
ran better understand exactly how far
off a section of this community is and
how
time after time will write about this
crap and people still don't shut up so
my lesson to a lot of people is when I'm
not saying that on Twitter I'm letting
people take else you might want to
shuffle you know you might want to just
stop talking right so other words go
ahead and Bell Diller on Twitter and if
he ain't say nothing don't say any yeah
yeah don't say nothing right we got
silicates of the JDK with superjet 2520
also chests simple facts the ue5 devil
impressive yes but it could be done on
both the Xbox series X and the
PlayStation 5 does pf5 have a better SSD
at ion yes it can just work clapping
we're gonna get like a stream in assets
faster but you still need a powerful GPU
to process those assets into enter the
Xbox a series X get the other ones that
I miss something I'll bring AG needle
with I don't know that's Australia file
I was super chat since anyone it could
show how good the Unreal Engine 5 looks
on the weak of heart I think needs to be
highlighted to make generation baby why
you got to do this super chat say
nothing a code is dropping the mic come
and put some bars in their code already
do is go look I hear what you say I look
for me I was impressed you don't saying
I liked what they are actually prefer
shout to solve because I actually prefer
the digital foundry breakdown video post
their take cuz I'm Wayde King I really
they started our storm I just showing a
game playing and then it became the
whole Geoff Keighley and friends in
everybody's attic and they lost me
adaptable know what we do what we do did
we talk about in the background he needs
to the same way these dudes want a shape
inside of Xbox and anything Xbox does
and it appraises do for giving you the 9
minute demo and 49 minutes of talking
what I want you to do is give us a
breakdown on what this is going to be
about so we can skip and leave it I
learn more with digital foundry and
everybody else than I did with quad-core
Keighley because I hated them in
separate sections of their own attic
they look like it was in the same house
goddess man quarantine it was horrible
and everybody talking about it was a
great show it was a horrible show it was
a great tech demo that was nine minutes
and you take take the rest of the show
and let me see if y'all really sit
through that crap it was and y'all was
talking about this we look at it
everything else but what was going on I
was like I liked the demo but I was so
frustrated after that demo I was like I
woke up for this look at the replay I
heard the night before what it was I
don't know exact idea man I knew percent
I'm a rule 5 thing and I still didn't
wake up I didn't definitely not like the
presentation as far as a whole as a show
the actual demo impressive technology
actually gentleman said something about
how it could be using conjunctions you
can lean out a substitute rap you can
you can use global illumination for the
lighting and ray-tracing for right for
reflections in by the way gears 5 the
series X version yes that's why they
focused so hard on this advanced GI that
they're using they're using a very very
high-end version of global illumination
for the series X 3 gears 5 yeah that was
pretty impressive man he looked really
good of rock formations when she was up
against the wall that's what about the
particle system no like the bugs on the
ground that were actually it's actually
a particle system they masked or
disguised this bugs right is my reactor
life right yeah I learned that from you
watching your video when you said that
because I thought they was actual buzzer
our acid or something but you said
Devils like the particles user from the
nanites technology something like that
yeah yeah and now you basically they
designed them and look like bugs I set
certain radius around the light that
those particles could engage and that's
what get that's what building a video
game is a lot of it is the illusion
right that's a particle system disguised
as bugs that reacts to light and it's
very convincing you use that word
illusion because Sony is used to using
smoke and mirrors I heard they showed it
on I don't know how true that is you
know there's a lot of obviously and you
know what I really liked at the end is
you know with the whole flying thing
like that shows like what set pieces and
stuff can look like next-gen so you know
I'm really excited to see exactly you
know what Unreal Engine 5 does I mean
they so supposed to pretty much
confirmed that hell-blade 2 is being
made with that
so it's an engine that still that's for
yeah yeah yeah did you guys know that
it's upgradeable something more you can
actually upgrade to 5 and then utilize
this new features very cool it's
definitely a nice thing because you know
regardless what people you know besides
the whole Twitter thing the whole
console BS stuff on Twitter you know the
demo was the best part that we've done
all week and it was you know besides
goes Kashima which we'll get to that
later
but you know but at the end of the day
we got that part so let's get to the
cards get to the smoke bomb obviously
the first thing was you know the rumors
are going around initially
I'm saying that this demo could only be
done on PlayStation 5 star that rumor
who said that well I will reach a group
of people did that
you know great the great Tim sweetie
I'll put this out there he said up the
Unreal Engine 5 Tecna would absolutely
not be possible at any scale with
without these breakthroughs that Sony
made and then he said that PlayStation 5
SSDs are far ahead of high-end pcs and
this is again the CEO of epic so this
retro rampant shout out to um Linus tech
talk who had some things to say and
fired some shots back he pulled out some
SSDs that apparently do exist that are
faster technically then the what's
called a place 85 s DS so look let's get
into the semantics of the demo and then
shout to solve cuz you know hang on I
don't cut me I gotta ask you let's go so
how come because number one when he says
the breakthrough Sony made remember this
is a marketing thing right so I and I
just want to really take the time to
piledrive this [ __ ] because secondly if
you're talking about if not for these
breakthroughs it wouldn't be possible
but three [ __ ] runs on a 970 Evo
language but just an even closer because
you know I'm saying like you're on a far
slower P this is Dion on the PC and your
demos running just fine
what breakthroughs are we talking about
yeah this is when you get the money in
one hand and you're talking out the
other side when you get the money in one
hand the one hand the money is gonna
tell you you can only do this here and
then we're going to let the demo out for
the world to use the world that has no
was I thought it was breakthrough that
only Sony can do but that's when the
money's talking here I don't think that
this is even about money with like well
I think their long-term game is like
we're gonna scratch Sony's back and
they're gonna drop these place issues
exclusives on our front door like eight
is a good point because what in place we
do now run by the epic store they get so
at the end of the day look this caused a
lot of controversy on social media a lot
of the PC community was very upset at
these statements a lot of the Xbox
community was very upset and then such
through the PC people
you start attacking they hardware this
is my girlfriend what do you mean
shout-out to solve because you brought
it to my attention solved that I want
you to be that as far as you know it was
it was revealed that it could be run on
what the 2070 and where the standard SSD
that exact level yeah running a forty
frames per second or something like that
well like dealer said then they didn't
they they were running it on a twenty
eighty max Q on a laptop but initially
one of the first things that came up was
yeah it was something that was far far
less powerful running twenty seventy
Subaru exactly kind of similar in a nine
seventy Evo yeah right correct
so again let's get to that you know as
far as that whole country what are you
guys thinking about that you know does
this I'm gonna say detract from what was
shown the fact that reports now coming
out regarding the SSD a regarding the
fact that the demo actually can be run
on other ohhara or do you believe it or
do you feel like you know what it will
it will run but it but it won't run as
efficiently because of the the place 285
SSD tech and actually let the other mods
you guys could jump off and I mean what
what part I mean it morning and it comes
down to it and mats will agree when
you're flying to the level like this
which we were all impressed by there are
ways at the very worst case scenario
which by the way may not even need to be
done at all to make this a little easier
for streaming solutions that aren't
quite as quick secondly you're not
really factoring in the hundred
gigabytes of real time in-game assets
that I've been talking about forever
with the virtual memory that's a big
deal and if you're able to use that
compression block to speed up the
transfer of that data from that SSD to
that Ram you you're no longer limited at
two point four gigs per secondly SSD
okay right that's just how it works so
if they are not able to get enough data
out quick enough to do a flying secrets
like that which doesn't seem like it
would be the case then they can always
reduce texture resolution or something
else to reduce the amount of bandwidth
this needed there and add some damn
motion blur I don't know I'm sorry I'm
sorry I forget okay so well demo was in
30 frames per second so it did need some
motion
it'd be like that 30 frames per second
or 1440p and still was chugging I'm just
saying I'm sick okay every mi bugging
out here everybody else see the frame
rate chugs and certain sequences and
then the I truly believe that this is a
lie on the part Christopher I go on
through the gaps we have learned about
these gaps and loading sequences and I
and I know that we will have loading in
the next-gen please don't believe that
just because you got this magical SSD
there will never be another loading
screen you're going to set yourself up
for such a level of disappointment a
flame on next gonna make no sense but
when she was going through the cracks
Tim Sweeney said and I quote this was to
highlight the assets up close mm-hmm you
could've did a whole lot of things you
could turn to the wall and looked at the
asset up why didn't you have an open
doorway leading to the next path that
that's my opinion of it because I've
seen this in Tomb Raider I mean other
games like God of War
when they're going through doors or when
they squeezing through something the
hidden loads room yes the hidden loads
means that we have been such accustomed
to going forward and I believe that this
is in disingenuous on their part when
it's big saying that there's no load
swings because the SSD is so fast you
will never see another load screen the
end of load screens is here you didn't
need to do that crack then okay who
would walk in between the statues that
was there to show the assets up called
Jack it's coming for y'all
I'm not develop at all purchases
consoles in multiples multiples when
people moved in the armchair develop our
shared commentary yeah you gotta
understand that the Xbox Microsoft and
Sony are not just trying to sell us on
systems the industry as a whole is
working together to sell us on tech I
guess
and they're all working in conjunction
so the message has to be the same across
the board no matter if they attack each
other this way or the other this
gamesmanship whatever at the end of the
day the industry has to be on the same
page moving forward or we won't believe
it right this is why this is why these a
lot of these arguments get on my nerves
cause like you guys don't take
everything they tell you at face value
see they he said his fat Tim Sweeney
said it's not possible and he ran it
back right when people when people got
in and got into him and saw this doing
this at him don't they say him he ran it
back he's oh yeah everyone says fine on
the series X right so what you have to
again the obviously the bag was there
especially the bag was there there we
will talk about that in a second all
right
beyond that it says what you have to
understand is that the industry as a
whole is trying to sell you on these new
consoles not just Xbox not just place
Taylor yeah when you hear stuff like
this mm-hmm
and you start picking and choosing
what's what's gonna be on your car your
console choice and what's gonna not
gonna be on your on the competitor
understand that they're telling you what
they're telling you what you want to
hear so I'll say magic oh you said media
pious huh that's what it is huh you
think they would want to show that off
on something like a series is a debut
for this new cutting-edge engine like I
would have wanted to show it off in the
best way possible if I was going to
choose the consoles it's there's a big
gulf there but you know I like with this
place these four five demos and stuff
like a lot of people who kind of
obviously it was kind of debunked that
the whole thing about like all that this
demo at such a fidelity would work
wouldn't run on any other hardware right
so that was debunked by Epic Games
themselves by but only from China basic
yeah stream man sorry tell us about that
stream yeah I mean so basically you know
they were talking about the the epic
engine and stuff and they said that even
though they were showing the PlayStation
5
you know demo running in the background
right because some people actually throw
at me like hey mods but you know that
was not running on PC but that's not the
point they were talking about that this
particular demo can be run on PC and so
if it can run on mo now 970 whatever
right it can run on xbox insects as well
at the same level of fidelity well they
find my body King download Unreal Engine
5 demo when it comes out and from the PC
I said that yeah yeah yeah yeah so we
will be next year we will be able to
actually test it no problem but at the
point I already want to make because
like it sounds like we are we are trying
to downplay the the the SSD speed in
PlayStation 5 yeah because like you know
let's get [ __ ] straight because like
there's no doubt that PlayStation 5 has
much more capable as is the much faster
right now the real question is what this
is is they can be used for now we know
that it's all about the data streaming
to rom and so basically you can actually
you can load more data in the rom so
then obviously the the geometry looks
better and whatever right now the real
question is will playstation 5 because
like even though SSD will be able to
provide this data to the rom will the
rest of the system be able to cope with
processing this data right and because
like you know it's it's fine I mean it's
like it's like imagine if you are you
are throwing a party like or you are
you're having a friend I will deliver
you like hundreds of hamburgers like
every minute right but will you be able
to eat them ugh if you eat all these
hundred burgers you know in a minute
better put a note you will stop throwing
up right so my really question is like
it's nice that PlayStation 5 will be
able to deliver all this data on the
flying but CPU GPU and the rest of the
system will still have to be processed
this in this data right and like people
I mean I feel like developers talking
about the game designer stuff right and
I get I get it that like maybe some
things might not be
possible next book city sex at a scale
that would be that will possibly be
possible on playstation 5 in the future
right but we don't really know what
things that we what what kind of things
we're talking about here because like my
personal feeling is that playstation 5
basically overdid SSD and they they
could have invest a little bit more in
of the rest of the system because it
sounds like Xbox CD sex is more balanced
system overall in my opponent or AB are
more balanced and you're absolutely
right they did over invest but also they
were limited at 36 to you and we knew
that that's why I talked about a month
before they announced this stuff because
we knew they were used in hardware based
backwards compatibility and the amount
of C used is very important when it
comes to how this is going to work right
so yeah I think you're absolutely right
they did put a lot of money in the SSD I
would have saved money there and made
sure the system came in at 400 bucks no
matter what hundred bucks cheaper cuz
it's a big gulf there also keep in mind
that it's hard to measure performance on
an SSD speeds alone it is faster it's
definitely more capable but it's also
one of the most expensive things in the
box and for a next-gen console where if
this thing is running a game on any
other platform except for just a PS 5
you'll never ever see the full game
design unlocks of something like this
kind of bandwidth with with with game
worlds and with gain how games are built
right we have two developers on the show
not too long ago optimus code in Chris
Cornell absolutely and again people
don't believe the stuff we say but
they're saying the same exact thing if
these games come to PC if they are
third-party titles like Ragnarok or
anything else that runs it 30 FPS SD to
its fullest potential because it is
built for a common denominator not being
a mechanical drive on PC and the Xbox
Series X drive is are faster than even a
SATA driven SSD on PC correct so people
have to understand that if that demo
were really utilizing the full speed of
PS v SSD that unreal v demo then she
would have flown faster and by then you
can't even tell what's going on what's
the point
and another another thing I wanted to
say is that like people talking about
like utilizing hardware to its full
potential but the thing is like hardly
any like hardly any developer will be
able to take a full advantage of this
hull of the above consoles like like in
like a year first two years really right
because like you know there's a lot of
new tech there right you know things
that have not been done in the past
right at least not on the in the console
space so we're talking about totally new
technologies in a console space like
variable right shading machine learning
am i two girls with you I mean we can go
into that like that's a big thing and
people tend to ignore it and I didn't
hear anything about like this thing
being on on PlayStation I mean check
what DLS says 2.0 does on PC right with
ray-tracing and stuff right no I mean
you know you know like so I don't think
that this demo is retaking full
advantage of these consoles especially
that even epic China did say that it's
still are not optimized even the dealer
said that in the video so you know the
things will change they're constantly
updating the you know engine and stuff
so I think I think this demo was
definitely geared towards the
PlayStation in this factor we know that
radiation is heavy CPU it brings down
you know whatever you can use right
performance based it teardown it'll
bring us 60 frames per second game down
to probably like 20 frames per second or
something and if you don't have the GPU
overhead to push it through a brute
force it through it won't really work
well I believe that this engine was
specifically designed in that fashion
because it's not using traditional ray
tracing is using the luminous engine now
I'm not a developer I get all my
information from Mozilla so anything
that you hear me saying isn't probably
me breaking it down in my little brain
and him regurgitating it back out
alright from all the stuff that I do get
a chance to watch and I'm probably the
layman as far as everything else goes
with everybody else but what I do
believe is
I believe that the Unreal Engine 5 will
help the PlayStation 5 do their form of
ray tracing which is less taxable on a
system that doesn't have the GPU power
or the CPU power to compete with the X
that's my opinion
let me get these super checks real quick
as we definitely have some comments to
send into space is the first one at $5
super Chester bug from the Unreal
particle or Unreal Engine 5 particle
system is called viagra okay salute to
him oh no no no elemental peels next
kill me for debunking to Cydia the
engine putting Deb's on the spot I gotta
get ahead get keep going I'm gonna have
to switch accounts because I think
they're off the chart no JD game I see
20 hours of a chat you know what's good
about having the more part don't don't
read that because then we'll have to end
up reading stuff twice just keep going
it's off on the screen jump on the task
jump just crazy so I hope I didn't miss
anything but here we have JD given with
the fire all of super chat when you feed
starving people Salty's they will say
just give them a real game no control
was an interactive you know what's good
about having a more powerful CPU and GPU
you get to spend that extra power anyway
that you want Allah using the additional
CPU GPU cycles to to do additional
decompression of assets or ass it's an
IO pipeline no shoutout to toy stocks I
am man from our deity with fire so we
check mats bring Metis 100 hamburgers
and I'm gonna eat them faster than any
SSD
we got it tested elven elemental pio the
actual next gauge in the ascendant
exclusive says that said to go to IGN
this is not Microsoft's first gaming
console and it's not they don't know how
to make sawhorse so they don't know how
they are diesel they know what they're
doing so they know what they do HSA I
this screen of their vomit stencil is
not becoming me right now super chat so
the PS 5 can stream data faster info
faster into the system but the Xbox
series X can do more with the data once
it's there a la the games can look
better
hello over 100 gigabytes per second more
memory bandwidth on series x the demo
wasn't running on pc they were running a
mp4 of the PS demo yeah I think you
mentioned that kiss move sorry admission
chat last meatball files super chat if X
Box decides to show the tech demo
instead of game what would be the
narrative Wow baby is up with that it's
gonna be it's not the games I want to
play destroyed that techno it's a tech
demo it doesn't mean anything that would
be initially dropped straight down in
the demo to allow time for loading all
that comes up there next in the flying
section it's a sage if you look at the
bottom of the corner it's a little
loaded thing in the bottom before she
even does that and they confirmed that
none of that flight thing with all that
was on Rails no that was that shout out
to all Mike Dodds we also which as Sony
has how many IPS that use Unreal Engine
throws his hands up days gone there's no
one okay stop and and I think days gone
can use it I mean hey maybe we can get a
rematch I got an opinion
used to be flying around the world with
some decent frame rates I'll be fine sad
- sovereign I like this gun shots I'm
cocking it they're both monsters it's
just that one monster eat one each
monsters for breakfast the book of Acts
along for that way you spit bars get the
last one then we move on that was lovely
that was it cool so we all cool we got
our book order we all quit look at the
end of the day I thought that was
impressive
you know I'm saying now my whole thing
is I'm kind of a kissable of an actress
peck of like okay we got a stop when we
see our low favorite logo in the corner
you'll say when you see the place say so
you see that triangle you see that X or
whatever I get it you don't say dudes
are excited you don't say I still at the
end of the day to me this is a demo this
is a representation this is a showcase
of what could be
yes it's running on a hardware I get
that noise stuff again my whole thing is
energy you know I'm saying so at last we
were upset right because there wasn't
enough gameplay shown at one of it right
now we have an event that is not its
gameplay but it's not of a game that's
coming to release I like the whole tech
stuff I love the potential I'm which you
get shout out to the lumens in the
raytrace I'm and the bug a k-rock in the
earth I'm over about 8k rocks up is fire
no say all are saying is less slowdown
this is a multi like Attucks it this is
a multi-platform
engine now will there be some things if
we you know there was an Xbox Studios
are using [ __ ] okay listen now if it
comes down you were saying that this
game looming in the nanites
is coming to release right and then if
we get that and we're doing our side by
side I would love to see how the
PlayStation 5 tech at the SSD the i/o
compact come you know compares to the
Xbox SSD and the philosophy architect I
would love to see that when they finish
products but I am NOT going to cap for
something that is a tech demo we doesn't
know I can't do that it just gets me
excited about potential and that's
me but that's what I got on it anybody
else able to jump in on this whole let's
do an epic walk half the stuff back and
then the confirm it's gonna be you're
gonna be tested on piece of yourself
when it comes out and then it runs on PC
and X in my hardware all that was is you
know Tim Sweeney had that meeting with
the PR from PlayStation right before
that now this is the stuff on each man
will have that guard warm to you by the
end of the summer now you guys say these
words you know I got a I got a comfort
man he said one week Sony ended the Sony
is silent narrative forever trust me
nobody's when you start throwing it and
we wanna stop allowing you to do what
Playstation do put that money out anyway
like I was saying like what I see is
people keep running with this narrative
the gameplay wasn't shown at the Xbox
games show on inside Xbox first of all I
will allow you to look at medium an
actual game that's coming out packing
something that you're gonna put money on
a cent an actual game that's coming out
an actual game that you're going to go
and put money on to get um and it's
gonna also I'm going to talk about right
infinite an actual game an actual game
you can actually go and put money listen
what you saw in inside of Xbox is a
glimpse of what you're going to be able
to play what you saw on the quarantine
in with Keighley is something that's
been happening with you know Cory Glee
and friends keep taking their friends
alright so you know the billion
downloads Buddy Club told you that in a
couple of years you'll be able to do
this hopefully all right Microsoft said
for your dollars
this is what you're getting now and
you're upset for them to show you what
you can expect or you upset what a
company that's giving you absolutely
nothing no games a tech demo that you
won't be able to take advantage of it's
only five or six years later gameplay
King it was no gameplay it was no
gameplay for noobs no system because you
didn't see no controller you saw a
prompt all right so let's let's keep the
same energy man like when you're sitting
there hopefully looking at your demo
over and over again and I'm free
ordering these days and I'm hoping that
they're watching this demo on repeat
when when your actual visuals of an
actual game actually comes out and you
back to the demo to imagine what it
could be that's going to have the big
misstep okay now no but I'm going to be
playing later and you say the same or
twos not coming out like they can't play
I can give you a scenario where gata2
never makes it to this earth give you a
scenario when they actually get buried
and they don't make it out of the front
door this is this is not Don matrix the
guy that should not be smoking man never
again
this is filled Maxim explicit this is
why you're afraid could you know exactly
he will get that aurelius title because
he's not gonna make the same mistakes
and he's machine he's not just because
you're thought you which came breathe
when June and July hits you when you see
their halo on your neck and when you see
this gel over here with all this Unwin
ass lips space engine it's on your neck
who did you gotta wear that like this
yeah my god I get I gotta get myself a
chance Bing for any light at the end of
the tunnel
mm-hmm if filled ominous Maximus Spencer
shuts that damn
there is no daylight for you but yep
afraid your poke the bear okay then they
said this is how you set to generation
oh this is what inside Xbox you're
supposed to do if filling they're right
about that though in a way because I
don't think you should show some of the
power of a 2022 super 16s in two threads
and all that memory bandwidth SSD and
you debut that with indie games and
that's what Microsoft did what I don't
agree with that at all but I would also
say that calm down with the bug demo
alright cuz it did look great this got
some really cool features you'll see a
lot and I am a fan of it look at my last
video but at the end of the day look at
Red Dead compared to stuff the towel
Metro compared to doom eternal run at
double the frame rate you know there are
sections cutscenes are not that look
really good in modern games and you know
when it comes down to it this is nothing
compared to what you're gonna see in
five years six seven years okay be
excited for the future of gaming really
so kind of the message absolutely but
King they say an awful ball does some of
the best know what happens when you
stall for something this is the thing
let's say any of those games come out
right now
right that little patch at the bottom of
the screen that told you that series X
when you purchase this game it's going
to give highest fidelity this is what
you over to this this is called purchase
and what a safety net this this is like
when you go trying to get a safety on
with key they say he said you could jump
in without no fear with the lesson when
you go to Best Buy and you can't
warranty on your game when you get a
warranty on your system this is a
warranty you can purchase with
confidence knowing it's gay
go with you to the narration say you
only have $600 right
you only got enough for a controller a
system no I mean now from what I'm
hearing only like 400 but you got this
movie going get complete a system yet
impasse and those games that you
previously purchase will get you through
those lean times so when you see that
part with that patch this is what that
whole conference was this is what I
disagree with dealer that whole
third-party developer giving the light
to the third party those games look way
better then it because those are games
I'm let me let me explain why break then
let me explain why those are theoretical
benchmarks that they will hit knowing
that the actual hardware they will
exceed those right but these are actual
game oh I I agree with you 100% and
that's the beauty of it even if we
disagreed like I love here's the thing I
completely understand what you're
talking about
my thing is I want Xbox to have as many
w's as possible Don Mattrick made sure
it is a series of URLs coming fast it
would rain for years we various let us
find out the Terry Myerson contain
bottom line people thought we were
making so and so bottom line is that I
don't think people understand how much
power is in series acts I don't I don't
think people understand this and when
you debut remember in 2013 is a shout
out to Tom Warren I don't know you know
I don't know what he knows that I didn't
seem like you knew much about the
hardware or really anything but when it
comes down to it we had so many games
where developers come from PowerPC and
and cell architecture and 2013 we had
Ryse son of Rome drop your jaw right
killzone all these next-generation
looking game and when you have this much
power with no
bottlenecks oh my god you better you
better not show indie games right and I
got slow that's literally an indie game
but that's over although series sex is
so much more capable than what bright
infinite showed you and I'm the reason
to help late to shut people down moments
like yeah at the debut you can't be on
top of the mountain screaming power and
then show an indie game like that
Authority oh yeah yeah I got a joke yeah
we don't this indie disrespect because
they did not come close to selling you
any I get a chance to put your
Lamborghini out there and take it full
speed on the Indianapolis on the next
gen I hate you they showed they showed
up to the date dress up one sock on da
they should have done more they should
have done better because there's more
power there often and again like that's
just me one better for Xbox I get that I
get you know what the ceiling could be I
get but we decals Landa no medium we not
go slanting oh right way about medium
I'm talking in depth about that game
Xbox I'm gonna buy most of these games
and by me saying this criticisms not me
yeah we attack them you know and it's
not even necessarily you know how the
power is what the power was like it's a
combination of stuff it's combination
that they've taunted power and they
showed these games out right it's a
combination of they introduced this as a
third part this is what third party
gonna look like next gen right and they
show you know that the the highlight of
the whole stream they didn't show
gameplay it's a highlight that they they
show this is a gameplay feature and most
of the games that had game plays the
games you didn't really care but people
did enjoy what they saw it on what's
right and then they
streamed in 30fps Cognito little bit
young girl stop acting like it was a
whole bunch of SIA thieves and grounded
game in a watch that again I watched or
I brought through those reports there's
only one game that looks us it was the
vampire game with the wack no it's not
about if they looked bad it's about they
did not come close to leveraging the
hardware these games did look next-gen
and even medium right I mean like the
interesting thing about this game is
that like it's really you know using
this SSD and stuff because it's all
about these shifts from like one you
know weird were to the yeah I'm telling
a polar studios so I mean and and I'm
sure that the game will look good but
but I agree with with dealer in attics
yeah but like had they had they shown at
least one first part the game even like
extended oh got that little broom for
the beat you guys he's saying that the
only way to truly show the hard part
yeah bad well with triple a third
parties this is not hard
oh no what listen only gonna be hip-hop
music with your techno music trying to
get your Avon here's the deal we knew
that it was the third party showcase
exactly but here's what's third party
cyberpunk
Batman man all call remedy all this
stuff that looks amazing and the model
baby you don't shoot a whole gun in the
oven doozy
it's time to start shooting shoot
everything you know
a lot of those games exist on PC already
today like this that really new date
ain't been out leverage not leverage the
hardware with us ok I'm gonna tell you
it's not new for you it's new for me max
yes he said he said I never had a TWiki
before this is a new trick it's not all
about just what you feel thanks did not
show you the hardware and that was the
thing they didn't convince you if the
part of the job is to convince you to
buy the next-gen system they don't care
they don't care that you're impressed by
it because they know you're gonna buy it
check this out mmm Microsoft didn't care
at that point in time well I apologize
he said he's sorry that he got you all
lathered up hey I'm sorry we didn't show
that Batman the cyberpunk moment for any
money people have a little hyperbole
going in you didn't expect now if you
watch Ekta RDX for two weeks
yes we told you we knew this is mostly
double a double a kind of smaller games
we knew that first Mac we already knew I
knew the list the day before that's the
problem
when I saw that list I was like is there
really surely they've got a key on a
moment where they got you know they
didn't put on this list and they're
gonna show you a third party game that
really uses the hardware and I cannot
sit here and honestly tell you that if
they had done that I would not be more
excited for the future of you got a
little on your because I had to list the
day before they told you for Batum what
was going to be on there after you read
the list you said these got something in
the bag and we no no no no don't even
show me some so me show me some gorgeous
software I'm sorry all right let's take
from this stamp what all right knew that
one thing that could have easily had
that they had control over was at least
telling people about the time to
exclusive what they didn't do right they
didn't do a good job of messaging to
wait out there and meeting that I think
it was what was that dinosaur looking
game let's go because control wanna be
game and control one again game which
comes aboard medium o mediate the fact
that they had those as timed exclusives
which they all look good besides the
Dino game right what do you think about
the wall the wall journal and they had
that in the bag and they didn't show
they bag they like this they acted like
they everyone there was a hole in the
bottom of the bag attic to say yeah we
got this and for a dist amount of time
but no you don't see y'all was looking
at this little tech demo so he said
nothing about Sony we talking about Xbox
and they could
let me ask you question let me ask you a
question she's saying a champion some
garlic on the floor sure boss exclusives
do Drive a platform no I just want to
see some only 80 power up on the screen
no he's coming spectacular yes we gotta
be we were so strong with the logic and
what not going crazy people but Alyssa I
get it they didn't show gameplay they
market it wrong I get it I was not happy
with that I want to see next gen
graphics yes I get there all I'm saying
look at this top down game illogical
mods all I'm saying is compared to what
was shown this week right which is not
so nice mentioned event right but that's
not my point my point is the narrative
that a lot of people are spewing telling
you what the energy of the streets is
this is like yo what is true I see
stroke and they said this is how you
show a next-gen that's what they're
saying they said this is the way you do
it compare and all I'm just saying let's
be real you do they really matter does
it matter that 50 people consistently
dog xbox no matter what they do on to us
now I'm just telling you what the energy
is that energy people will pumped they
were high and see but the energy would
have come to inside Xbox was way worse
than that right they would not have even
our you know take this street down
because it was so bad now they really
uploaded they took no the stream down
and let them actual high quality stuff
okay kiss balls I think we got okay I'm
just sick and tired of hypocrisy
I'm just sorry while you're sitting
there rubbing around on that demo
[Laughter]
on that demo pause I'm going to be
playing some games I saw an game said
I'm definitely mine
a destiny to win their call get off your
destiny mountain oh hey my favorite
people you are the mayor of destiny
screenshots and laughs at me every day
I'm a big fan everyone on this panel on
King David in particular I'm big fan of
King David I'm just saying that I you're
saying I know that we're having a good
time here right there's no money with
the $2 super chat game action king
that's dead I was the first one yeah
yeah get it off before that yeah sorry
guys I'll get them we got cam McNair
with the fight off super chat can y'all
explain the purpose of 8k textures
running at 1440p
high quality textures you know downgrade
it still look fantastic
every good to user element appear with
the trellis which at the flying sequence
was a transition to cutscene and gave me
jump me okay maybe still running in real
time no it's still hold on now we got
kicked back yeah see true game up in
there
this this Jeff must be running in re the
engine I'm gonna miss one thing the next
one I see is a true gamer mmm already
hype Xbox tried to gather crazy
PlayStation on another level love the
podcast next gen gonna be fired
oh yeah that's a fact that's a fact
shout-out to Mariano and you will know
my name is the Lord King David when I
lay my vengeance upon you book of acts
gotta give the book of X for that
continue then we have Oh shoutout to
asteroid rocky woulda took our chat
great show great commentary thank you
sir whoa let's make sure let's just make
sure I get a couple of these did we get
the moon from senjutsu sage she
initially dropped straight down in the
demo to a lot of time for loading okay
if we get all my yeah we don't we all
the way up we up okay okay just make it
I'd like to kiss moves broken ps4
controller oh yeah shops get show the
last absolute only games exist in beta
demo form which would be scorn and
bright we have Juno's 23 best part most
of these game is going to game pass yep
yes Martin
being the mayor of destiny hey if you
can't if one of your sheriff's catch
someone play destiny wait I got a
problem with this new so much I'm just
saying this other stuff out there to
experience people doom
tonal for as fine well how many you FRA
st. play to prematurely
I know adding man that you are doing
yourself a disservice yeah waiting for
it to come to game so I'm waiting from
the replace a doom for doom good to you
that we all caught it's great we have
now we have all night with the two
dollar superset 8 K at 2 K equals 16 K
all right we all felt when we felt about
this joint but there was another reveal
sushi so when the failure is out here
it's easy suck up let them put you the
mouth someone needs to clip him saying
that honey when he say he mushrooms yo
name Jesus gags ghost on deck what is
the vibe so look man let's just get
ready yes I'll set it off because I told
you you was hating man he was he will
meet one when I all jokes aside it
really they really did a good showing I
thought it looks like it look really
phenomenal I will say this song it gave
me it's a prime know it gave me more
breath to the wild exploration vibes
water that door I didn't get I mean we
don't school it's right here we go
so all I'm saying is this like I will
say the definitely surprised me as far
as the acceleration to win kind of
showing you we're stuck you'll shout out
to the to the to the grass store out
there the individual blades of grass is
looking really fire I was I was digging
that and on yeah like the thing that was
really cool about obviously we have the
exploration but we had the stealth and
we had like the samurai so I was
definitely impressed me got the two
different variants you could complete
quite a game completely two different
ways I thought that was fire I mean well
eyes kick laughing I mean but if you're
in the stealth mode that's the only time
you can swing around right like which
I'm not sure it looks like you can look
right
I doubt your speed around
same ride armor right so I don't like
that I don't like that I have to choose
to play that way I want to be able to
swing and latch onto stuff whenever I
want to play but they kind of gave the
impression like story wise then I think
you don't start out that way yeah yeah I
have to play the samurais first from the
way they explain that gameplay it's it's
a path you choose definitely get RT
paper
the way they explain it's like the game
pushes you to be a ninja or sham or
whatever is the first one to the second
one a shame right whatever man I don't
need yo-yo stuff right now aggressive
but it does look like cool if they don't
move or shoot to play is the IQ you have
they track down a thing shout-out to you
no I'm saying like again just to
character ball itself give me my come
low head low you know saying I have I
have my cake physics going you know
cinematic effect was a cherry blast look
if you got cherry blossoms why didn't
you play Sakura not cuz yeah throw your
controller and now it's not I'm too old
to be getting mad at games but on
controllers on bosses yeah I want to use
it so shout out to that so get it gave
me that Assassin's Creed tension vibes
what do you think about the little fox
fox was go we go pet the animals we can
say hey there's a shrine over here
apollomon is a file you follow this
follow the birds a very environmental
storytelling
now I will say this note on the samurai
combat I don't know yet I don't know I
like the slow dev but maybe it's because
I played check rope but like in the
low-key combat I got a see more now I
will say this off they had the the sole
Khalid omitsu it looked like that match
characters solves you know how we get
down with all yeses with the missionary
to hide over the water seems my hopeful
for it oh I said like I like my initial
reaction was it was this I let me let me
preface this was saying I'm he
fraud I'm getting it day one samurai
ninja stuff a baby
Oh me come here sorry blah that's when I
when I was watching it and taking notes
those watch it I'm like it's a whole lot
of Assassin's Creed DNA in this game and
there isn't necessarily a bad thing but
I was hoping for more and what I meant
by that and I'm like I was talking
before these open-world games need to
evolve right a it just sort of felt like
everything they showed was kind of in
that typical open world fair obviously
with with uh with the coding that I like
right you give him feudal Japan I'm
biased biased um so the thing about it
is when it came like - when he
infiltrated that the docs right and blew
up the docs yeah I see was looking at
the wall act like he was whack you got
to distract them to get behind them and
stab them up stuff like that that I've
seen in another open-world games the
same thing went when they were on a
horse and you you go by someone by a
tree and you snatch it up because you
need you need those items to build
something that's Assassin's Creed like
I've been doing the real tab snatched up
for a hundred plus that was an AC
Odyssey like you know what I would out
of it it just feels derivative and
that's and I wanted more from the game
so I don't again and this is me just
seeing it on the surface again we don't
know we have details his cog is all in
and I'm all into a point I think it's
more than always about to marry this
game late if you had played AC Odyssey
you'd feel different alright but here's
a date where AC Odyssey got the same
arrive with the complex realities
everything that game is the same game
every
pirates one-year is Egypt Odyssey is so
such a class ahead of every AC like it's
the second best RPG of all time you need
that much to play that it is
legitimately an actual RPG now by the
way port a an RPG actually or just
action game reproduction is okay
no no RPG elements then you're upgrading
your armor you're upgrading your
skillset so again much like C AC Odyssey
is an RPG masked as an action game right
because the RPG elements are easy enough
to get into that you don't like if
you're not somebody who's into RPGs and
into like menus and stuff like that you
can still play the game and not be
frustrated by a very accessible very
super accessible so again like when I
saw this I'm like I've seen this before
right so the way it differentiates
itself that I saw from the demo was
obviously the stylization of the world
right the way the world is is sort of
drawing out it looks beautiful
umm the fact that even the camera angle
is much closer the camera is up closer
on the on your player so everything is
the action is it is more up close more
and it's very intent it's very cinematic
so it's just a matter of does the actual
game when you're down your controller in
hand you're playing it does it
differentiate itself enough to make it
stand out from what I seem Assassin's
Creed Odyssey and sheykh row making this
game looks lacking like I'm not saying
this might be good it still looks fun
but like from combat why's that right it
doesn't have there's no foxes mess right
things about the open-world be different
right yeah and in open-world usually you
know you have your waypoints and you set
the Waypoint and you go to wherever you
want to go and this they figured out a
way to make it more organic so you're
not actually in a menu all the time
looking at a map you're finding you're
finding ways because what happens
these open-world games is that you're
constantly doing that picking your
Waypoint going from A to B and and
you're not looking at the stuff around
you that's why when I play Red Dead like
I left all that I go I said I'm just
gonna look at my grandma I said breath
little while because that's where breath
to the wild does it's like oh what's
that did this is let me go you're not
looking at the map every five minutes
465 question box telling you what to do
that's great that's great but then when
you go to the shrine I'm like okay how
many shrines rocks am I gonna blow up in
that is my concern fur that's legit so
for it to stand out for me obviously
story wise right these these
single-player driven games this only
puts out usually story character that's
what brings me to them right but beyond
that it's it's a formula that works for
them and works very well for the very
well for PlayStation I'm just concerned
about that but either way I mean I'm in
day one so anybody you know you do got
to point out that sucker punch his last
game was trash according to the Sony
guys cuz it was an eighty you know
that's their words not mine like when I
play the second song but they think it's
trash because it's an 80 and 87 it was
the first game that really showed off
with that console could do yeah it was
Samantha me mad you saw a ghost of
shiitake mushrooms I'm a little empty
myself but also that's kind of a
demonstration of the world and I'm sure
it'll be more lively and and stuff but
there is stiff competition out there
honesty in witcher 3 is the best RPG
ever made which is what coming I mean
all those damn hamburgers
I'm still making those Ninja Gaiden
I know those games were fine still look
like more fun to go so Tsushima at least
for me absolutely you can get Harlem
Knight 116th Street in a building 20,000
Sega's ps3 spin-off Yakuza kenzan looks
like his wave has much better saw played
in DOS of Tsushima but you can you can
Ken's in was never localized in the US
look up on YouTube see this little plane
just reach I feel that I just like the
cinematic you know choice when cherry
blossoms in black and white but we gonna
move on oh man we gonna get you man what
did you feel the ghost is here was your
thoughts yeah I mean like I mean you
guys bring up the Assassin's Creed for
some reason but like I don't really feel
bad to be honest with you I mean I mean
I I know that everyone's like maybe
different stuff like I don't know maybe
because it's like totally different
setting like you know if you know each
other on did you play sorry how much of
Odyssey did you play go to game shaming
here we're losing focus
Matt's I think the Odyssey thing was for
me it was the one he bent down and
started ripping the trees out the ground
with his butt cheeks that's we need
picking resources up off the ground like
that that was exactly like odyssic on it
but I get what you're saying Mads what
were you saying yeah anyway like maybe
it's just the setting and everything
right and and like yeah I'm actually
getting a little bit of like sick more
of a secure all kind of like you know
vibes and like you know I wasn't really
blown away by it because like a I'm not
really into this you know you know
Japanese kind of like and not games
overall but like setting and stuff right
and like but no the you know what's
interesting is that if this game because
like I played like you know trying I
mean I will tell you how much of on you
know Isis games I've played like you
know I played quite a lot of like maybe
20 20 hours of like assassin
Sanskrit or origins I played previous
Assassin's Creed against but they know
through the RPG games right I'm talking
about like you know the two the three
actually two three I didn't play the
first one so these were more like action
games and I enjoyed them to be honest
with you so if this game like has no RPG
elements other than like you know you
can like do something with your gear and
whatever right but you don't have to
grind and you know do a level up and
whatever it's more about action-oriented
for a second they did say you should be
gear has specific purpose based on the
style of play and it will encourage you
based on your specific style for us the
ghost in the pig I agree - I didn't see
skill trees and and yeah yeah maybe some
light RPG Omega gamma gamma came right
but it but if it's more action focused
games and stuff I mean like it's it sure
is going to feel different than the
Assassin's Creed Odyssey and stuff right
or any other assassin I mean maybe the I
mean I guess if we compare it to the
previous Assassin's Creed games maybe
then yeah cool yeah I mean like um it
feels way different than any of these
other games in my opinion but like up
like I'm weird right I don't know you
know like I don't see any and when it's
okay it's okay much don't worry that the
first time I saw this game is what one
of the first themes I've seen the you
know this guy on the horse and stuff I
was like hey it's more like Red Dead
Redemption thing really right you know
you're right in there horse and stuff
right so there's no I guess you can ride
all kinds of things in video games right
now right it's it's really difficult for
any you know or original kind of ideas
but yeah there's some self mechanics and
then stuff right it's more
action-oriented game and stuff right
probably not going to be as long as the
Assassin's Creed games right now so yeah
I mean like if the gameplay feel if the
actual game feels good and you know it
plays good and stuff and the story is
interesting and stuff I mean yeah I made
to get right so yeah but I
no I I don't get the Assassin's Creed
vibe from this game at all but that just
me right you know do we get yeah you see
her youth anyone man sorry no actually
let me tweet it out but you know we will
learn from my mistakes and I will never
last thing I wanted to actually say that
is that like if we were to compare it to
with any of the at least like to last us
in screwed games I mean this game like
people were saying that all this you
know I'm blown away by the graphics and
stuff and to be honest with you I think
that the substance free the games
actually look better than this game
right so that was the stream though and
even the reupload seem like absurd a low
bitrate yeah but like still you know the
you know I know it just like this awful
screen names feel more denser in terms
of like yes you know things you know
it's it's like like yeah if the grass is
great but like use good grass everywhere
and it was very open like was it great I
don't think we see enough point for what
we've seen I will give you this body and
this way you're you're honest something
is that they I was concerned no no I
just don't you're not on to something so
the whole thing is that I did I was like
concern cuz you just see like one bear
or one Fox right you see like a bunch of
NBC you didn't see like one thing
Assassin's Creed does was that density
of city and population like they
probably will have it but for what we've
seen right now
it's just I might even have a box that
leads you to a crack house it might be
it might have sense it might have
something to do with the fact that like
if like in origins for example you get
to Alexandra you've got this huge city
huge buildings and thing it just looks
stunning so maybe it has more to do with
the architecture and the fact that you
know like you know the you know nine
hundredths weren't that impressive and
all you see
man saying that the mom said in Valhalla
is like they're gonna have to figure
some way to make certain cityscapes
impressive because like to the nature
yeah I got it though Salado it is those
Mongols man I feel yeah I agree with
man's the Mongols could have built
better buildings for me I'm good wow
that's the best podcast remember ever
yeah one thing I think I will say for
King gets it is the fact that I didn't
mention other influence that I saw that
I loved in another reason why I'm in
despite what I feel is the tenth you
influence for me 10th you are my
favorite I created a genre called Merc
and murder and I murdered them yes that
is my favorite from way back in the day
all right
it's the room each other story the first
time I got 10 - stealth assassins picked
up the Japanese version I went over hogs
house we were playing I had the tech and
arresting I said I need to throw this on
yes threw it on
we spent the rest of the day just taking
turns going back and forth just just
rappelling up onto the Builder jumping
down onto people slicing their necks
like in us so this gave me that vibe
again and yet we haven't had a chance of
game in WoW am i my choice if I can like
add excitedly you give me just the
choice to pick one of the other I'm in
all the way told a fellow I think you
got the choice okay we go he's in the
beginning did you get it well I think
the way the way the story is set up okay
well let me let me start by saying this
right I have a couple of reasons why I
may not get this game all right and it's
because of the mixed messaging from Sony
I don't I don't know if they're going to
do smart delivery and the Last of Us one
on the PlayStation 3 not knowing that it
would be a 60 frames-per-second 4k
versions coming on this game is coming
out at the end of the generation so that
is a genuine concern this is I'm not
trying to give them double bucks
I really don't concern over there come
backwards compatibility base yes yeah
I'm try to give Sony least amount as
money as possible
all right because I want them to do it
on their own it's like you know you got
a kid you want them to have as least
amount of support because you want to
see if they're strong enough you hold
your bottle okay so going into this I
was amped this is the only game really
that I was truly am from their stable
mm-hmm that they showed like probably
four years ago and it's finally coming
out now at the end of the generation
we're going on to the next um shout out
to the leek is that actually forced this
game to come out um
because y'all was going to get it next
gen I'm not gonna go into the fact that
did it or did it not look super
downgraded because it didn't look like
what they showed before like when they
showed it before like oh my god that's
not Jim
oh my and when I saw this I saw a barren
world left and ruin with a fox oh very
smart [ __ ] David come on so yeah it's
very very how they place the little maps
out over here this barren world monami
of pubs pub Jeana beginning so this is
what happens you think that I need a
piece by version at e3 is everything
however no I think they showed you the
PC version alright I want one you're on
your twenty eighty okay so in seeing
this game then Holly was presenting it
it sovereign made sure that I went back
and watched it in 4k we got
when I did watch it I watched him in
YouTube's 1080p which it made it look
actually hard Tim's washout right so
then I saw it again in 4k now when I
picked up was the Assassin's Creed
visuals when an enemy sees you and the
bar starts the growth in the level of
sight that they see you it's completely
ripped from Assassin's Creed salute the
state now I'm playing Assassin's Creed a
game that is a hundred plus hours the
level of what they give you for your
buck is unprecedented the world is huge
and I understand for some people that
may be a little bit daunting it was
daunting for me in the beginning but you
cannot discount the value that you get
for your dollar right now I'm looking at
this game as I look at Assassin's Creed
as an Android phone my S 20 and I'm
looking at the ghost of Tsushima as like
iPhone you know it's like AC Odyssey for
dummies I think I think this is the very
beginning of it now in sameness the
world intrigues me
yes because I'm into that channel 5 I'm
into also I'm going to I'm going to get
the game because I was super amp for it
regardless right this is the end of a
generation type of game and going into
it I think I'm going to be caught out
there again by these dudes by purchasing
and I and I truly don't believe that
they're gonna have any backward
compatibility in the fashion that you
guys think right and I believe that
top-tier games are games that you're
gonna be forced to buy again remastered
um and I think this is going to be one
of them and I think I'm going to be
caught out there because I wanted that
in 60 frames per second but why is it in
black and white and it doesn't do 60
frames per second right why are we stuck
in this at 40
like it's going forward it is always
going to be 30 frames per second like
hey it was this thing 4k was it because
there was nobody in the world so I think
4k it was a 1440p and why isn't the same
energy held to this game and I'm gonna
bring this one point back hip-hop I hope
you still watching hip-hop I hope you
still watches good because I told you
everything shown at that incited xbox
blows that game away
this is disrespect this is they should
have show pong so go see Shiva does that
look did that look impressive more than
the ascetics while games T oh hell no
oh hell no especially no mark the lower
courts podcast we do not agree you see
this right here I'm putting this on I
don't care what you say this this says
Xbox and I'm right you can arguably week
ahead argument that this is one of the
best end of the generations for Sony as
far as far as the first of all I'm just
concerned last of last of us that's
about it oh my god we gotta get this and
they better knock down great debt we're
gonna be washing it's great on that mods
which is it no I just wanted to say that
I've seen the leaked last of us gameplay
so I can confirm that the game really
looks good and obviously I'm not going
to leak anything but really even the low
low quality low quality Last of Us part
two looks much much better than this
game to my mp and so I know I'm not
hating on the game the game looks good
I'm talking about ghosts of Tsushima but
it just like I don't know maybe I've
seen too much of a you know Unreal
Engine 5 demo right with this super
geometry and Afghan stuff and maybe
that's why every game it looks poop you
know you know kind of flats right right
it could be can we all agree that this
game definitely got
great like that it's not a bad thing
it's like this game definitely doesn't
look like what they showed us and I
don't with with the fire everywhere know
them in the in the in the flossing
leaves like it definitely looks nothing
like that
well I asked if the narrative release
impresses you know that yeah interested
in the narrative no no I wanna play - I
wanna play I'm jacking like this is the
worst thing I ever seen no but why are
you glossing over the fact that has been
downgraded I didn't say it was I did
felt it was a lawyer yeah I felt from
what the initial showing what's a couple
old it was like very dark and I felt
like the the lighting was much stronger
this didn't feel a little flat I'm not
gonna but it wasn't to the point well
not y'all I'm saying it like this looked
terrible because I would just say that
like when it comes to combat style like
I joy like I don't think I could go back
to something that's not on the parsha
kuroh now like you know I'm still gonna
play because I love you know I I have a
huge thing that's missing in my life
called splinter so and it looks like
this is the only thing that's going to
come anywhere close to it in terms of
stealth wise but like I guess you know
what she mystic King is he are you at
that point because of the fidelity or
the dirty phrase that no I got a history
in pro and I have a phenomenal
television that's going to boost it I'm
gonna put on the boost mode to boost it
um my thing I told you my biggest thing
I don't want to have to purchase this
game again to see it in its true form
and I think that's a detriment because
at least tell me this is one of the
games these last generation games are
the games that I know going forward I
can pop my disc in and I can play it and
it'll grow up but the lack of
information has me super to be more
transparent because I don't see what
iswhat would they show before right so
do is okay what they show before is that
was gonna be on a Playstation 500 or am
I had a loss and I have to wait for a
remaster to get what they show what they
promised before so your whole thing is
because of your distrust of 70 and you
wanted rework yeah he were to see smart
delivery on the coin you want to know
for sure that if you approach
this game that when the capitis file
comes out you're getting it for free all
the way in on 50 you want your game to
work going forward like you want your
purchased be your purchase and work in
six months is what you say yeah I wanna
know about all that unreasonable King
David thank you yeah so um let me at
first where are we any stunts that you
sage found our super chat sony lawyers
will be in touch with his land a cream
our cease and desist is with the $5 yet
I'll definitely check out ghosts on PS
now what huh Mon Lloyds I wait for the
PS 5 version as that game pass deal
wearing mods if you guys got something
to do like I get that we're keeping you
like yo you know we do this to every
guest but I say that's bad the shells
running long yes I get it you might be
hungry
yes we're almost done yeah much as much
as possible until I can get on RDX and
I told you just let me know go to
sunglasses on my show
something cookin Smitty Smith with the
fight also which I feel dumb is a Jim
Ryan is a naughty dog you better have my
money for those servers or Last of Us -
ain't gonna be the only thing leaking
around for teh here's $2 for the love
King gives exports every show I don't
need you are destiny after podcast
that's pretty much all I got everybody
Tsushima but um anybody else left on it
and then we're more - the last thing
this is annex topic we know dealer could
not wait to talk about paper marry paper
is that a [ __ ] that's why he gave you
the cute alright
no I mean seriously I'm serious no no go
please so I'm just gonna show guys let's
add me on great topics one of my
favorite podcast in the world thank you
and again you guys keep doing phenomenal
work all of you are amazing
again big fans are all your King David
you gotta be on the show kognito and
again except again big fan
you guys keep doing great work hey chat
and I'll bail no that's a little brother
babe they pull it up mods you're allowed
to stay just by adding kicking y'all
what are we gonna get what are we going
to cook so coming in hot so paper
Mario's come out from the Nintendo
switch it's coming out in July what do
you guys think
whoa make it quick also make behind you
love it look I still got to read these
super chests from last week at the end
of this yes I will jump in look I'm not
even go for it
I don't I've never played it no game I
don't even know what it's about
yeah please tell me
what is the whole height probably about
this paper Mario's pretty much like an
RPG like Final Fantasy toss away okay
yeah it they they've kind of like one
away from some of the stuff that the
original games did but it's still always
a really fun game to play it kind of
caught me off guard because like
Nintendo just be like yo here it is
coming out to like there's no build up
to it they're like you're right or go
state they don't even care Tendo knows
they're like that express lane beside
PlayStation and Xbox like they don't
care what day comes out what I saw check
your Facebook real quick but yeah that
it goes to that and you know I really
enjoyed that they had that game coming
out because it gives me a reason to keep
the Nintendo switch that's been
collectin does for a little bit so it
dislike a premiere title yes it's one of
their big games that they you have every
other be the super chef from stage two
you gotta get that so we got a photo
super charm stitch well this is where I
part ways you are about to fall asleep
I'm gonna give you the same opportunity
I gave Dillon you can bounce man we get
it like we do I gave him the bushes a
movie he'd do it in the bushes
that's it we fade we caught up on the
only super chair and I thought we had
some before that no no that was no
that's all oh yeah we got I cool so soft
Paper Mario man we yet it was funny is
that this game came out of nowhere and
it's gonna come out and it's gonna sell
like gangbusters and they're just gonna
laugh all the way to the bank this is
what they do they they didn't need a
direct didn't need to you know multiple
games around it they said just said
Paper Mario here you go oh I think
they've been they've been getting a
little bit of flack for not talking as
much as Xbox has just cuz you know you
expect to direct at certain points like
respected a big direct than what we got
was a smaller anything that people were
a little bit less impressed with but
they working you know I always say they
got these people these people
quarantined in the treehouse
don't know it so um games are gonna come
out and Paper Mario is one that we have
not seen for quite some time
it has a nice following it's gonna sell
gangbusters because that's just what
they do
I'm super impressed with that
I like Paper Mario and addict said they
did definitely walk away from a lot of
RPG elements that they had in the
beginning but I believe that is because
of Mario and Luigi took up more of the
RPG elements with the combined moves and
stuff like that so I think they left all
of that stuff over with Mario and Luigi
which I love that too yeah um so and I
think that probably will debut on a
double screen switch Plus and I hope you
come out with but now I'm super
impressed with I'm more impressed with
this than I am what goes into being that
it's called I think that's always like
made like that's always made their first
party sell more it's cuz they're the
like a third party like would you buy a
switch like you're you you get third
parties but when like a not as that at
any like cyberpunks they can literally
launch at the same day as a cyberpunk
game be like we good decided on our
platform people ain't buying that over
here I know that this game was gonna go
forward to whatever system that they've
done we but we know for sure that we
know because they was gonna have like a
dual cartridge situation so I got a I
gotta stop you there you got put the
fraud alert you can keep compatible with
the switch loki really excited about
this I know that and llamas the reigning
switch champion defender of day one
paper berry all right
yeah now like I'm sure it will sell like
you know a lot because you know most of
these you Nintendo games do and I I've
heard a little bit about this game I've
seen the previous games like never
played any of them to be honest with you
so you know I can I would lie if I said
I'm excited about it but like I know
there is an audience and like and I
don't know there's something about these
Nintendo games of people like freely are
drawn into and like this this anima
animal crossing' people are doing crazy
things with a game and in this game like
like playing hundreds of hours although
you know I mean actually you know I will
be on the topic actually my son is
actually like you know gatherings are
like saving you know every every every
penny right now to get a switch right so
he's halfway through right so you know
he plays on my xbox and he's got he's
got tablet right so he plays all these
games I'm like listen I'm not I'm not
okay right maybe I will maybe I will
help him a little bit like when he's
like eighteen eighty percent into like
you know collecting the money or saving
the money right but like you know he he
needs to end
that's himself instead of spending money
on you know lollipops in other he's got
some something to look forward to right
so yeah who knows maybe he will get a
you know but I think like if anything he
will probably get like Mario Cart and
that can serve and we'll play together
then sir Oh
salute yo we got a wrap well um attic
soggy I wouldn't get this is a chance
that we miss I'm gonna have to read them
because you don't have access to oh yeah
so obviously last week we had a crazy
panel while I wasn't part of it that
week so uh we're gonna go ahead and read
yeah
than later into the show super just
because we definitely you know we want
you guys to be understood that you know
we didn't miss it on purpose it's just
that chat was going so crazy and and no
one on this cast knew how to actually
look at the super chats in general so
the thing is like when you put the top
chat right because that's I switch to
the top chat but in a moment it doesn't
show them yeah you have to go we're
gonna have to give you access to all
right so I'm gonna start with Johnson I
mean we got fight all the super chair
from Jonathan be hold on I'm gonna let
y'all finish for IOP as the longest in
terms of long as a facto super trap from
Jonathan be I heard the PS 5 logo was
created by one person too and that is
definitely outshine everything else Sony
is whoa we gotta do it the road slow
progressive lung keyloggers welcome to
the bronze we actually have a uh we got
a an announcement here soon about that
but we'll get into that in the next
couple weeks because a oh we got a ten
dollar super chat from a Cyrus Bart I
think we know all let me pause this
music I think we know all of the
Microsoft to make these disclaimers we
we are in the Jan where games are for
any graphical mishaps especially
Microsoft games or related games also
shout out to the guests so we got a two
dollar super champ from phantom Kraken
aka Joe Senayan Gooding on tribal
tonight Co Hans a new I've been saying
this for a while
inside Xbox needs to go not you're a lot
of stuff that we read on the show not
all but suddenly stomachs between
something okay we got a $10 super trap
from KITT smooth when the first show
their germs it's so one okay Oh Jim's
when first parties shown their gyms
distal eyes this conversations going to
be a big waste mind you only Oh looking
at the bad gangs like blood rain AC
about how and Madden disappointed for
not showing enough oh we got a fight I
was super chat from pixel they've shown
such rails with gameplay so overhype
also better notion
a full shade or through to EA Ubisoft er
fronting for Indies we only got like
maybe ten left okay Jesus
the the law we got a $5 to chat from
Jonathan be the Lord's Himself could
come down and hand everyone a physical
copy of ugly to and people will say is a
60 frame we got a $5 super chef from our
in b2 to be fair the Last of Us 2
trailer didn't say gameplay can we
assume that that was going to be shown
on actual gameplay what's real on the
streets anymore
oh my lord we gotta find out super chat
from Michael aka been straight finest
people cry too much the game were good I
feel people will crap about Xbox no
matter what they do
what's the hate needs to stop hey it's
daddy we got a $10 super truck from JD
gamers so they should have to say ok the
game still look good in next month they
won't say it again now what how are we
going to be in this new cycle I guess
Sony's willing to talk or willing to
talk mm-hmm man there's a few when I got
a fire I think we read some of these
somebody's right but yeah just think we
don't know which ones we were which one
we didn't right we gotta find all the
super chap from Philly Eagle want to say
something so want to say thanks to the
guests for their perspectives without
being hateful much respects a little bit
wish for contra craters with - yes Liu
Bei about the rails though ok so he's
not a $2.00 to protect from Jean g8g
what do you think Sony goes sure about
backwards compatibility we see the money
of that be about compatibility one thing
yeah we did we got a to to super chat I
can get popcorn to go for my last of us
by death singer
I guess he's talking about it's it's
it's a cinematix it available via petit
we got it five dollars super chat from
R&B one PS five games
in June if they don't say game play will
people keep the same energy
I doubt it that's the god world
Microsoft needs to learn when Sony go
look you guys I'm gonna go ahead and
mark it here and I will finish these
next week cuz there's still like 15 20
more that's crazy
I'm about to lose my voice shout the
Forte with right now find out a super
chat let's throw it up my oldest loves
xbox always playing Mortal Kombat my
young let me just yeah let me just
finish it there's only liked in life
hope I'm raising my children rights
aloof would say oh he example unlike
bots will by sense which continue
all right listen listen a good example
so let me just go and finish because I
didn't notice there's only like a little
bit more above where I'm scrolling
through we got a five-dollar super trap
from pixel bit he lying right now he was
good at so just new home boy ain't no
way so do developers better than the
dx12 you as the PC standard come on fan
we better have up yeah I'm just we got
two dollars super track from R&B hip-hop
gamer did any def praise the PS 5
cooling system oh my god let's get this
game up by choice real quick that just
popped a great show Thank You Lourdes
and guests for keeping me rollin the
whole show looking forward to the next
generation game salute Lords and guess
excellent show Thank You brothers a
little game of my choice get catch up
catch up addict alright so we got a
fight on super track from PC gamer hey
hip hop how much is Sony paying you bro
oh I think these are the ones you guys
missed
we got a $5 super track from Shane
Tomlin so Sony has never missed the
pubic oil probably like saying the probe
was 4k instead of 1440p
plus mayweather with the gel for beating
his girlfriend we got a 5 pound super
chef that singer I'm hearing a whole lot
of Sony loving and damage controlling in
this panel we've really not buy so
you're asking for a friend
so he was asking for his friend are you
guys having buy his last one yes we do
so we got a $5 super trap from title of
we only got 6 left from Titan 2 9 2 7 9
3
I know you're all busy lies but please
come together again after the next gen
starts to hit us up with more
our sony going to get this Xbox work mmm
do we got a $5 super chat from true
gamer like hip hop said Xbox has to
create cloud to market their console
PlayStation is clout and that's facts
and numbers don't lie a sure let's go
alright so it looks like we only got one
two three five left
JD gamer $20 super chair I'm willing to
bet kings I'm willing to back Kings bet
and say that I want to play racer it
will be on the best plate on the Xbox
series X and if I want a first-person
shooter
TBS I don't know what the or horror game
Oh Terry versus year the game will be
played on the Xbox series X here's 24
the pot I don't think you guys did that
Ben the game takes a bit G with five
dollars to Pichette help hey we'll
infinite slipspace n should set it it
will be on bar and graphics aimed ESET
Xbox Series X is the benchmark for
next-gen we got a ten dollar super chat
from we only got three left thing comes
from neo metal
yeah telling me today he'll mental y'all
killing me today great show can't wait
to finish it later shout out to hip hop
and read some solid people gotta go
spend some time with the fam Happy
Mother's babies and all the moms mmm we
got a $2.00 super check for Michael and
vexed its finest yeah key break them
legs the book X we got a $2.00 a super
chat from a gamer by choice I think Xbox
needs to get some marketing people they
market Xbox like Microsoft markets
services a service operating systems etc
you don't you don't hype servers and
operating cippolini to hype game so you
do got a point that whole download and
then we got a $5 super channel slow-mo
Aaron Greenberg camera 4x4 inside Xbox
is running on the Frostbite and outlet I
really finally let him do something
again and he's shooting break look if I
missed any other ones because I was
trying to read them as fast as possible
I definitely apologize you know we'll
definitely try to be a little bit better
on that it's just last week was so crazy
I was looking at the chat after I was
water
while I was doing door - the chat was
just so fast there's no way we're gonna
well show all of them how to do this
from now on no doubt salute everybody
that pulled up man I was a crazy show
everyone today salute as well we'll do
the poll we're out of here
new ILP poll this week with the latest
Unreal Engine 5 tech demo reveal running
on PlayStation 5 hardware how important
is it to you
when gauging playstation 5 performance
the choices are a very important gave me
the truth Bill generation tech or
PlayStation 5 be not as important it's a
multi-platform in jail not a real game
Oh see I don't get it these next
generation consoles could do 60 frames
per second oh the choices are there all
the people who Rock the Vote all that
good stuff you already know so look at
the chat everybody we will get a new
poll up hopefully later tonight and then
tomorrow
let us do our I'll shout out the dealer
gaming obviously that pulled up our TX
podcaster you catch them on Tuesdays
salute them boys over there was it the
grounding game a d-pad soccer coach
Eastwood Tim dog and am I missing
anybody else I think I caught everybody
paddle but salute to them brothers may
they always do anything they always show
the Lords lunch your soccer yeah got so
salute dummies always love and of course
we have more to gaming that Nets own and
the tech specialist mods game and pulled
him in the house where can the fire
people find you what you got going on
sir and thank you for inviting me to the
one-on-one series you got a dope 101
series he's doing I was honored to be a
guest on that now what I was doing man
so salute to you and tell the people
where you can find you what's going on
thing breaking up oh yeah okay also
something otherwise well thanks a lot
obviously for they invite really
appreciate that always I always
appreciate that and love the energy and
stuff so always happy to talk a little
bit about tech and some gaming as well
so well obviously you can high-five me
on YouTube mods gaming and Twitter Matt
gaming
PL so yeah
Ayesha was always every week great
guests as well Billy was cool as well so
yeah thanks a lot
thank you brother bear always a pleasure
man also check about laws of gaming
Garnett some fantastic tech articles
that's always poppin always doing this
thing and like I said please support
this brother great channel a lot of tech
information always positive and even
when you go out ever xx always laughs at
people just says okay bro that's your
preference it's up to you like bods is
so chill like salute the bonds man
always doing it up for the community
Lord and catching up with all our super
checks and being very spicy and
disrespectful to go so quick if I do man
you can find me on Twitter at Lord
addicts IOP I can't do the extra stuff
man my voice is gone
yeah you can find me on youtube at
gaming adits and you can find me next
week coming back here again drinking
this profile you can find me doing that
loadout that's right though and that's
sold in the bushes my man getting rid of
this so let's go anyway
in the building I've made my Frodo big
shout out to deal in the monster will do
send the record straight
and you know of course you guys can
Cathy our Lord sir IOP on twitter and
yet sovereign on PSN xbox live you can
catch be once again playing the ghost of
Tsushima prequel a sciata seat introduce
you so much Landy today disrespect oh
you can find me in these twitter streets
king david OTW
beaten back these ponies teaching these
ponies exactly how to bend the knee and
is not for free they have to already
have to pay to argue with you that
that's we've established this oh please
man if you have you know and i don't see
it as not in color speaker color
since you say it's real quick oh yeah
it's out of this a psychological sucker
punch kick listen listen stage I'm sorry
bro but I mean place of my size and
speed I see that's all I can say oh my
did you catch me at our Kos this week we
don't have no reveal shows so I can
definitely get that statue up and get
that set around it's a real good statue
um
follow us on tick-tock podcast is on
tick-tock so cold air and check us out
there
mm-hmm also we're streaming all over the
world now oh yo the beam is broke yeah
we actually have one in red too but it's
over there now I didn't get it because I
have a peanut head in what I like to do
with my beanie is pull it up at the top
make it make it a high B neelaveni if
you don't like it that high you can
smack it back I'll own podcasts toys up
with the channel so you got your beanie
as you get you get that fitted you get
adequate hold you're not gonna hopefully
we get better yeah I love it associated
with playing Assassin's Creed after it
is so
you know you didn't see what happens
with this ghost of uh missing demo stuff
kimahri oh shout out to Paper Mario I'll
try to sell a Dido would sell it but
it's cool you'll see but your solution
300 strong I was gonna hit that like
shot to the dude that always dislike
before we have all 400 in there man
Lucio salute to the Facebook Lords I
seen you off on the Isle on podcast
group on Facebook
salute swap mixer Lourdes or twitch
Lourdes I know we would restream when
I've seen the activity is always not
also chat show the bluff you see that no
restream bot someone from another
platform show them love man because they
watch it they watch ILP on that platform
they'd like to get some interest on the
mixer they did join us on Facebook we
see the stream join us on Facebook just
search a little podcast group we are up
there we also have Lords of gaming
network as a page so again if you want
to catch all the articles all that good
stuff when Mars is dropping his tech
information or velocity architecture you
could do that shouts of cars going back
because he wanted to end it up I didn't
say thank you for dear life for coming
through yes Oh 100% listen man when you
the moon yes such a big figure in the
YouTube streets and you can come down on
a little join our little platform and
hang out as family I mean that's nothing
but hats off and mods
yo listen we like I said we got
something cooking in the background um
but mods definitely every time I don't
understand something I goes well he's
I'm subscribed to him so you know he'll
pop up with a detailed explanation on I
don't really understand and listen guys
it's very good to say that you don't
understand things and you go to people
that can break it down you instead of
you running out here ain't capita fraud
it okay I know what's going on we get
the people who are the savants I'm glad
you said that because a lot of people
try to let I don't know everything it we
don't know everything there's things
that information gets disseminated but
it's good to go to people who have some
of that acumen that can kind of prick
some style stuff down in laymen's so I
agree with you King on that part you
know understand for sure continue no no
that that's just basically it because
it's a
other things like people is really
thinking and SSD there's something to
boost graphical output and are you
trying say are you trying to say that's
false
[Laughter]
Oh watch mods video so he to you so you
can be more informed and then less
informed and you don't have to look like
a real person
um it's the wrong stuff - today's week
is gonna be less loot everybody came to
chat with this out show less anybody got
anything else we got everybody enjoy
your Sunday we are out of here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]